representative power why don't you lead
okay let's start out by opening up the
oh
thank you
why don't we start by doing a roll call
yo yeah yeah yeah yeah
here
but with the Guthrie yeah
clerks here uh representative Salas I'm
here
um representative yukela here
Kelly
representative Allwood here
representative Brown
representative Cahill here represents
Davis
representative Tatro
representative Trey Levin
representative Gilman here
and we have representative run
substituting for representative majority
here
representative here representative
Gallagher here representative Hicks here
representative Howland here
representative priest here and chairman
turquoy present okay
now we'll open up the
executive session on
HB
36 I believe we have an amendment to be
introduced yes Mr chairman I recognize
representative managerputi thank you I
speak to the amendment Amendment uh by
2023-0026h so the only change that was
added was in line
if all of all of you have the amendment
okay
I think did you motion this I I wanted
to pass it and then I'm going to motion
that before you discuss it we need to
have the motion on it and seconded thank
you ought to pass
for Amendment
2023-0026h thank you Mr and do we have a
second on that
representative
okay now you may speak to it thank you
Mr chair
um
if all of you have the amendment the
only change or the words that were added
was line eight
the Consumer Price Index of all items
that's the only change or addition and
it
cleans up or gives a very clear
Direction so
um
that's my
motion and explanation thank you
representative are there any further
discussion on the amendment
seeing none will ask the clerk to call
the roll
all right
Vice chairman power
yes
representative Guthrie
collect votes yes represent Visalus yes
uh representative Kayla
yes
representative Kelly yes
representative Alward yes
representative Brown yes representative
Cahill yes
represents Davis yes
representative Tetro
yes
representative Trey Levin yes
representative Gilman yes
represented wrong
yes
representative magaputi yes
representative Gallagher
yes
representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes
and the chairman yes
motion passes 20-0
do we have a thank you Mr Kirk do we
have a further uh motion
um I representative manager Puti thank
you Mr chair
um I make a motion to adopt
octopass HB 36.
as amended as amended do we have a
second
representative to 11 seconds
foreign
seeing none clerk call the roll please
okay ought to pass on HB 36 is amended
by sharing power yes representative
Guthrie
click votes yes uh representative
lasalles yes representative Kayla
yokella yes sorry
representative Kelly yeah
representative Allwood yes
representative Brown yes representative
Cahill
yes representative Davis
yes representative Tacho
representative 11. yes representative
Gilman yes representative Brown yes
representative yes representative
Gallagher yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes and the
chairman yes motion passes 20-0
thank you Mr Clark uh is there any
opposition to this bill going on to the
seeing none it will go on to consent
calendar and who will be writing the
committee report
or Senate man chaputi yes Mr chair very
good that'll go make sure that comes to
me
but unanimous yeah but I have to sign
off on it eventually so send it to
Representatives Davis and she will then
get it to me
and that closes the executive session on
HB 36.
with that we will open up uh executive
session on HB 41 relative to public
notice of meetings for County
conventions
and do we have a motion on that
Representatives Davis
thank you Mr chairman um
I have an amendment it is amendment 2023
hyphen 0028h to HP 41 that I would like
to pass around for your consideration
uh for what reason does the I just
wasn't sure what I heard there about
whether it was uh ought to pass or itl
on that particular uh representative
stavis has introduced an amendment to
okay is there any discussion
you may
um the language in the amendment
um kind of cleans up the original
language it adds in the uh the
recognition that not all communities
have daily newspapers anymore and so
alternative means of noticing meetings
may be used such as websites Electronic
media and the like and it comports more
fully with other state law
uh concerning public noticing of
you're welcome representative Gallagher
um so
um yeah I'm just wondering about the
wording here where it says
um
in some Daily newspaper as well as the
County website
um so yeah I was
so if the intent
is to provide an alternative
for places that don't have a daily
newspaper with a wide circulation
then
does this really help for that because
it still says both it would still
require them to do
both since it's as well as rather than
or so
um yeah I'm just wondering if you could
expand on that
foreign
representative Gallagher is is correct I
do not believe though that the wording
of the amendment
precludes a town from
from not noticing properly noticing a
public meeting
if it has a paper or website I think
that the amendment is clearly worded as
is and can stand on its own and towns
can use whatever whatever media is at
their disposal thank you Mr chair
yes representative stavis I as I read
this I kind of agree with representative
Gallagher that it says
um
in some Daily Newspaper having a wide
circulation in the county as well as the
County website comma if one exists so to
me that implies
that do it in the newspaper and if you
have a website do it there
but in Gallagher's illustration
if you don't have a newspaper which is
becoming more and more prevalent
can you just do it in the website
and if that's the intent I'm not sure
this amendment
does the trick
correct me if I'm wrong on that I'm
sorry
thank you Mr chairman
um
pertaining to this amendment here
is confusion
in the way that it has been drafted with
regards to the grammar
and
um therefore
I
I don't recommend
passing this amendment as written
because it's just going to add confusion
so I will be voting against this
amendment
John
representative Gallagher
um so to be clear I didn't really mean
to bring that up and ask a point against
the amendment I was more just wondering
for a clarification
I'm wondering if we could do an
amendment to the amendment or is it too
late for that at this point it's too too
late for that right now do we have a
representation 11. thank you once again
Mr chair
um I'm not confused by the language the
the grammar it might be a little choppy
um but as an adult I can read that it
says
it'll be advertised seven days before
the hearing
in a newspaper as well as a County
website if one exists if the town
doesn't have a newspaper available to
them that will fit the bill
and they do have a website for the
county then it'll go up on the website
now some counties have a newspaper
that is published that covers a couple
different counties and some as
representative lucelles alluded to and
representative Gallagher may not have a
paper in wide circulation but I don't
think this prohibits anyone from
publishing
publicizing
noticing where they can to the general
give me one second I am texting the
clerk
is there any further discussion on the
amendment
if not
have the clerk call the roll on the
amendment
okay this is on the vote of uh the
amendment 2023-0028h
[Music]
by Shaman power no
representative Guthrie
click votes no
representative yokaila no did I do okay
on that one good thank you
uh representative Kelly
representative ourwood
no
representative Brown no
representative Cahill no
Representatives Davis
yes
representative Tetro
representative Gilman yes
representative rung yes
representative megapudi yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative priests yes
and the chairman
no
um adoption of the amendment fails
eleven two nine
thank you uh just for a point of
reference uh what I was texting the
clerk about
was
um
on an amendment what happens
if there's a tie vote
just for your information if in a tie
boat it fails
okay since that fails uh representative
stavis I assume you have them all
I do Mr chair thank you very much I move
itl on HB 41.
do we have a second
HP HP 41 itl
representative power yes
clerk votes yes representative lasalles
yes
representative Kelly
representative Allwood yes
representative Brown yes representative
Cahill yes
Representatives Davis
yes
representative Tetro
representative Gilman yes
uh representative yes
representative Gallagher
yes
representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes
and the chairman
yes
uh eighteen to two
okay I tell on that represents Davis I
assume okay is there any opposition to
seeing none it will go on the consent
calendar
okay uh close the hearing on Executive
and we'll open up HP40 through for
executive session relative to County
Commissioners custody and care of all
property
I believe we have a motion uh
representative Brown yes I'd like to
make a motion for House Bill 43 which
would remove oversight and transparency
transparency of County delegations to an
expedient to legislate
thank you representative do we have a
second
second represent Elward uh seconds
and representative Brown would you like
to speak to it or
basically the uh the effect of this law
would have which was originally put into
uh in place in
um
2005-2013 would take the oversight away
from the county delegation I happen to
be on the county delegation in my county
and I know based on our previous
meetings that we feel that it's
responsible for us to have oversight and
matters of this regard
thank you representative Brown is a
further discussion representative
Manchester
thank you Mr chair I totally agree with
my colleague on the other side I did
hear back from our County folks and this
is a good checks and balance to have so
itl is the best option for this thank
you thank you representative
representative treeleven do you have a
question
okay motion is to uh itlhb 43 the vice
chairman power yes
representative Guthrie
click votes yes represents lasalles
yes
uh representative Kayla
representative Kelly yes
representative Allwood yes
representative Brown yes representative
Cahill yes represents Davis yes
representative tree 11.
yes representative Gilman yes
representative yes
representative Gallagher
yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes and the
RTO passes 20-0
thank you Mr clerk any opposition to
this going on to the consent calendar
seeing none it will go on to the consent
calendar and representative Brown will
be responsible for the committee report
and that closes the executive session on
HB
43. hb70 we're going to put do we have
the oh okay
um
okay we'll go ahead and then and open up
the hearing on hb70 relative to
residency requirements for Deputy town
clerk
and I believe representative
yokella is has passing around an
amendment and would do we have a motion
on that representative Phil Keller yeah
so motion uh that we adopt uh Amendment
2023-0071h
second
yes Mr chair I'd like to second that
representative power seconds
representative yokella would you like to
speak to your Amendment yes thank you
um
I believe and uh that that there should
not be uh
any Deputy that is not able to
completely fill in the role of the Town
Clerk and so I do
think that there should not be a deputy
that is not domiciled in the town
and I do agree that there is some
confusion in the language in 669 65 that
ex it talks about a situation where
there is a deputy that is not allowed or
that is not living in uh the town and so
this amendment seeks to clarify the
language in both
uh 41 18 and 6 69 65 that there is uh no
situation that a deputy should
um not be the be domiciled in the town
and so
uh in uh 41-18
there is a reference to an elected Town
Clerk and since the um there is the
possibility that if the elected town
clerk steps down the the deputy
automatically becomes the uh Town Clerk
and uh that person wouldn't be elected
so uh We've struck that language as far
as elected and um
and also opened up the language as far
as the reasons why they weren't able to
provide their uh perform their duties it
right now it just said sickness
resignation or otherwise subject to this
RSA and so we're just changing that to
just sickness resignation or otherwise
not able to perform their duties
essentially then the the deputy town
clerk would automatically step in
um
and so yeah I'm happy to answer any
thank you representative your Keller
representative power uh representative
power uh just one point uh for everybody
last night I sent out an amendment to
this
and it was uh
number uh 66 66 and I made a comment in
that the that one uh
word elected on line seven they hadn't
Struck it through so this is the exact
same amendment I sent last night only
with the word elected struck through uh
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and I just would
like to expound on the the um change
under section two
um the Striking of that word appointed
and
clearly as we heard during the hearing
um I pointed out that it is the
Selectmen that do the approving
and it is the town clerk
that does the appointing so that's
further
um clarification as to why that was
is there any further discussion
representative
thank you Mr chair uh so in
in a case where we did have the
discussion about interim the deputy
taking on the interim if there is an
immediate need
so where is that if the deputy is not a
local resident
and is functioning as a deputy but it's
only an interim clerk because of the
unforeseen is there any scope for that
I'm not able to
would you like to answer that
representative Keller sure
um
um there is no uh
uh nothing in the language that talks
about interim
um Deputy clerk the the process in 669
65 is that if you have a town clerk or a
deputy Town Clerk and the town clerk is
unable to fill their duties they
automatically become the full town clerk
it's not an interim town clerk they just
become the full town clerk
and so that is going to be the process
going forward and there is no situation
in that ex that a deputy is not uh
domiciled in the town so they are
completely qualified to step into the
full town clerk role
and representative yokella's explanation
is exactly correct if you um on line 13
it just it does specify that the deputy
would serve as the town clerk until the
next annual Town election under the old
language which is the remainder of that
paragraph is what we struck that
eliminates the
the ability of somebody who does not
live in the the town or the district to
perform that position so his explanation
is exactly correct I I will say that uh
representative power and I spent quite a
bit of time ensuring that these two
sections did not conflict we and that's
why you got that uh Amendment last night
because we were still working on it just
up until yesterday so
um
is there any other discussion
representative
thank you Mr chair
um
between the two between the
uh
top paragraph and then the town clerk
paragraph where the
um
Stockman get to a point
the deputy town clerk
into the clerk's position
but
if that person
isn't
um
domiciled in the town it doesn't comply
with the state's Constitution
which states that all Town clerks will
be elected and members of the
Community from which they serve
um
I
I think it should well it needs to be
rewarded or reworked somehow and I I
think someone could uh
challenge it
with the
um
by the appointment of the Town Clerk of
someone from out of town and I also
question how that would affect
our elections if we didn't have a
properly
appointed
debt uh town clerk to replace the one
that left
uh because because they didn't uh
comply with the Constitution
it's by understanding that the
Secretary of State
I haven't talked to him personally but
doesn't agree with this
so I think it needs more
more time or more scrutiny I'm not
saying it's a bad concept I think is
good
but I just want to make sure that we
have we don't have a constitutional
thank you is there any other further
discussion representative Gallagher
um so I realize this isn't strictly
necessary but just wondering for
informational purposes if you consulted
with the prime sponsor on the amendment
I don't believe representative your
color
consulted with the prime sponsor
okay thanks sure any other further
discussion representative lasalles
I I think
uh the prime sponsor of this the intent
of of this initially was to open up
particularly in places where where
um the available
a reservoir of employees is rather thin
they could go outside the town to get a
deputy but I think the representative
from the Secretary of State's office
made a compelling argument that the
deputy had to be qualified there was no
question it's up to the Selectmen to
find a deputy that is qualified to step
in so I think the the bill the as
amended
doesn't do what the what the prime
sponsor said but it does clean up the
language and uh is uh worthy of of uh a
vote
uh representative Gilman
thank you Mr chair
um I just had one observation that I
missed in the original bill
um because it says
if the town clerk is
um
unavailable because of sickness
but the solution is to have a deputy
until the next election
it doesn't seem to
is the town clerk going to stay out for
nine months because they're sick for a
month until the next election
and that's my my observation wasn't
solved in the amendment and
from the original bill it was still the
same question
thank you any further discussion
seeing none what Representatives Davis
thank you Mr chair
um
while the
argue argument over wording about the
position of Deputy town clerk may seem a
little bit
trivial I wonder if it might
um be a tip of the iceberg
to a larger problem which is what
representative lasellis referred to as
the dwindling reservoir of people
available to towns especially small
towns to find Qualified
folks to serve in these vital roles
in ways that comport with the State
Constitution and the laws and I'm
wondering if it may it might not be
worth either retaining this bill or
further studying it to
um to open it up to a to some larger
questions that I think it might be
so further comment
representative
thank you
um I am trying to do a search through
the um through the state's Constitution
that the uh that the town clerk be
elected
and I'm not finding that language in the
state's Constitution so I do I do
understand that it's required in statute
that um they will be you know meet the
qualifications and one of the
qualifications are that they'd be in the
town but I don't see any
anything in the um the state's
Constitution that says that it be
elected so I'm not sure that that
um would raise any
um if if someone filled in
um and what you know for a time in
between elections I'm not sure that that
is actually unconstitutional and it's
definitely the practice currently and
has not been
um an issue so I don't believe that that
should be a reason to vote against this
thank you
thank you representative for some
further discussion representative
thank you Mr chair I I think the there
should be some discussion
with the Secretary of State's office and
from what I've heard of this discussion
there hasn't been
um seeing how
he's the one that oversees
the elections
um
and I I still think there's a a question
whether
um
they pointed Deputy town clerk that
lives out of town
would be a legal legal substitution so
that's one of the reasons why I brought
up the Secretary of State's office
because
he's obviously
uh more familiar with this than
any of us I think
um
all right I believe we did that
representative this bill does exactly
what I believe you're looking for
um
what I think I heard you saying was
that we should not be allowing somebody
from out of who's not a resident of the
town
it would be unconstitutional and that's
uh the amendment fixes right the
original bill you were correct the
amendment fixes exactly that
representative power did you have a
comment
representative thank you Mr chair just
trying to clarify in my head
um you're absolutely right Mr chair
about clarifying
but still it there is a statue where
interim if there is no election there
are Deputy who is not a resident
who's serving as a deputy can still
uh in a current practice they can act as
the
um
Clerk
and what if there is a special election
it's not the regular election cycle so
does that give them the leeway to do it
and I guess that was one of the Prime
sponsors issue was if the deputy Enfield
especially has that issue so I don't
know if he answered the prime sponsors
intent for this bill but
it's a question still in my mind
represent power
thank you Mr chairman I would like to um
remind the committee that
um during the hearing in fact the deputy
deputy secretary of state Hennessy did
provide testimony before this committee
and her testimony in her testimony she
opposed the bill as written therefore
based on that testimony we can conclude
that
the Secretary of State's office would be
in support of this amendment
um
she made it clear that it was absolutely
imperative that the clerk
the town clerk should be a resident of
the town in order to
properly
perform the duties of the Town Clerk and
she cited a number of reasons why
privacy running the Municipal elections
Etc
so therefore
again I'd like to say we did get input
from the Secretary of State's office
I I would like to agree with
representative power that we did get
input from the Secretary of State's
office
but I see that input a little bit
differently I I remember her as talking
about the possibility of appointing
assistant Town Clerks who could take up
some of the responsibilities of the town
of the Deputy town clerk if the deputy
town clerk was not available however and
and she and she termed that as a
workaround but when some members of this
committee asked if that person could in
fact run elections her answer was no
and and some of us said well then it's
not really a workaround which she agreed
to so I
I'm going to stick to my guns and say
that we need further input and
information on this bill
and on this matter thank you
any further discussion
seeing none would the clerk call the
roll on the Mr chair Amendment I'm sorry
I have a question oh go ahead thank you
very much
um
I know we have a motion on the floor
could another motion be made in regards
to this bill or we need to vote on the
amendment
and then another motion might be made
yes we have to dispose of the current
okay the motion is to adopt Amendment
2023-0071h for HB 70.
uh Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie
clerk votes yes
representative Keller
yes
representative Kelly yeah
yeah representative Allwood yes
representative Brown yes
representative Cahill yes
uh representative Tatro
representative
no representative Gilman
no representative wrong
no Representative megapody no
representative Gallagher
no representative Hicks no
representative Howland now
representative priests no
and Mr chairman
yes 10 to 10.
okay as an amendment that fails is there
another motion
representative yokella
I would like to motion
OTP
so that this amendment could be brought
we have a motion of
OTP on the original bill is there a
seeing none the motion fails are there
any further motions
representative Gallagher uh I would like
to make a motion to retain the bill in
committee so that we can work out uh
further issues with it that we still
is there a second
representative for 11 seconds
representative Gallagher would you like
to speak to your motion
um yeah um I think
um yeah I I like the underlying idea of
the bill
um and you it's just with some of these
concerns that remain
um unclear what exactly the answer to
them is I think we need to get some
further input um
so personally
um
knowing that in New Hampshire
uh we can ask the Supreme Court our
state supreme court for advisory
opinions I would like to see if it would
be possible
to do that about the constitutionality
of this bill since representative Tatro
has raised concerns about that and
hopefully if that can be done that can
help us make a more informed decision as
to how to handle this bill once
thank you
further comments uh
what what is that the actual motion on
the floor at this time I heard
discussion about
the current motion on the floor is to
retain the building committee which
would mean it would be taken up next
year
representative
was there a second on that motion
are there any further comments
representative LaSalle
I would like to speak in favor of re of
the retention motion
because the original intent of the Prime
sponsor was to open up that Reservoir
and we I think we all agree that based
upon the testimony of the secretary of
state that you really can't have anybody
who isn't qualified to be a current law
says that you you have to be a resident
of the Town well that doesn't meet the
the intent of the Prime sponsor so maybe
we can resolve this somehow where we can
increase that Reservoir without
violating the current status of the law
so I would be in favor of that
seeing none well clear call the roll
please
okay uh retain hb70 Vice chairman power
yes
representative Guthrie
click votes yes representative lasalles
yes
representative uh your Kayla no
representative Kelly yes
yes representative Harwood
yes representative Brown yes
representative Cahill
yes
representative stavis yes
uh representative Tatro yes
representative tree eleven yes
representative Gilman yes representative
representative mangaputi yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priests yes
and the chairman yes
motion passes 19 to 1.
okay motion to retain pass is 19-1 that
will remain in committee and that closes
next next bill we will exec HB 72
relative to public Librarians we'll open
up the exact session on that and
I believe we have a motion Mr chair I do
have a motion Representatives Tre Levin
what is your motion I'd like to
um present to you for adoption
the amendment to HB 72 which is number
2023-0018h
and what you'll see is
a cleaning up of a practice that might
have worked in the past doesn't work now
librarian would be retained by the town
excuse me for a term of office a set
term of office of employment
and I moved that did uh ought to pass
was there a second on that
representative save a seconds
and I think he uh you've already spoken
to it I did I'm sorry I spoke out of
terms all right
seeing none uh if every anybody has
their microphone on could you please
turn them up thank you uh we'll have the
clerk call a roll on a um
Amendment two zero two three zero zero
uh okay uh
representative power yes
representative Guthrie
collect votes yes representative
okay
representative Kelly
uh representative Arwood yes
representative Brown yes representative
Cahill yes representative stavis yes
representative Tatro
representative tree eleven yes
representative Gilman yes representative
rung yes
representative megapudi yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes representative
Howland yes representative yes and the
chairman yes
uh motion passes to adopt 19-0
okay the amendment has been adopted Is
there further motion
yes I I have a further motion Mr chair
what is your remote
I would like to propose I would like to
I move that we accept the bill HB 72 as
amended
is there a second
seeing none I will ask the clerk to call
okay uh ought to pass HB 72 as amended
representative power yes
representative Guthrie
um
collect votes yes representative
lasalles yes
okay yep
uh representative Kelly yes
representative Allwood yes
representative Brown yes
Representatives Davis yes
representative Tatro
yeah
representative tree 11.
yes
representative Gilman yes
representative wrong yes
representative mangaputi yes
representative Gallagher
yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative preach yes
and the chairman yes
uh motion passes 19-0
HP 72 has amended passes uh 19-0 as any
opposition to going on the consent
calendar
seeing none uh representative treeleven
will be writing the committee report I
assume
you're going to open up the executive
session now on HB 75 increasing the
threshold of County old personal
property subject to competitive bidding
and I believe we have a motion on that
yes Mr chairman like to make a motion
for OTP on this bill HB 75 this bill
simply changes is there a second oh
sorry representative Kelly seconds
and representative Brown would you like
to speak to emotion yes Mr chairman uh
HB Bill HB 75 simply changes the dollar
value allowed to be controlled by the
commit County Commissioners this
original RSA was passed on April 12th of
1959 So based on the inflation over the
last 64 years I believe this is a
reasonable increase in the dollar
amounts for the Commissioners to control
thank you representative Brown Is there
further discussion
representative man triputi
representative priest could you turn off
your mic please thank you thank you Mr
chair again I heard from the county
folks this would enable their
functioning day-to-day functioning and
they support it
just wanted to relay that thank you
for the discussion representative
um so yeah I support this uh
as
just in the short term but I think in
the longer term I remember during one of
the
discussions on one of the pre the other
bills during the hearing representative
lasalles raised the point of why are we
hard coding these dollar amounts instead
of having them indexed to inflation if
inflation is the concern that's the
reason for raising them now so um yeah
I'm going to support this for now but
think that we should look at coming back
to it later to possibly
um
make it auto index so we don't have to
keep raising it manually
further discussion
seeing none with the clerk collar
workplace
ought to pass on HB 75 Vice chairman
power yes representative Guthrie
click votes yes
representative lasalles yes
representative Kelly
representative Arwood yes representative
Brown yes representative Cahill
yes
representative Tatro
representative tree eleven yes
representative Gilman yes representative
wrong yes
representative yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes representative
Howland yes representative preach yes
and the chairman yes
motion passes 19 to zero
thank you Miss clerk any opposition to
this going on to the consent calendar
seeing none and representative Brown you
will be writing the committee report
thank you
and with that we'll close the executive
session on HB 75 and we will open up the
executive session on HB 80 relative to
taxes event status for County real
estate
real property lease for agricultural
uses
I understand we have a
motion on this
I make a motion to adopt
uh Amendment
two zero two three
zero zero two seven eight
is there a second
not
really just clarify some of the language
uh just one small
so shall not be taxed that's the only
change
thank you is it for the discussion on
seeing none I'd ask the clerk to call
sure
foreign
hb80 to adopt Amendment
h
uh the vice chairman of power no
okay
yes
representative Kelly
representative Owen
no
representative Brown no
representative Cahill no
Representatives Davis yes
representative tree 11 yes
representative Gilman yes
representative rung yes
representative yes
representative Gallagher
yes
representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes
motion passes 12 to 7.
thank you Miss clerk is there a further
motion
represent
ative
representative prison L word could you
thank you Mr chair
um I would like to move itl on hb80
is there a second
representative Manchester uh seconds
uh would you like to speak to your
uh thank you Mr chair uh I I think that
of uh the several County governance
bills that we've received in this um
session many deal with the balance of
power between County delegations and
County Commissioners
and care of the county buildings and
lands is one of those issues and so I I
disagree with the original intent of the
Bill thank you
do you representative color
thank you
um
I don't understand how this has to do
with balance of power this is just about
Taxation and so I'm just wanting to get
some clarification on that thank you are
you Rising oh you just want
clarification on this would you like to
answer that representative or
no
representative
thank you
currently the county does not pay taxes
on their property and it counters to say
shall not be taxed right and the
decision is made by the entire
delegation and the executive committee
in some look so this gives entire power
to the Commissioners so the shift of
balance of
power checks and balances are offset on
thank you representative further
discussion
if I see none I I have one point on this
um
well I disagree with representative
manager puti's explanation I will say
the one reason that I will vote against
this
is during the discussion and the
testimony it appeared that the issue was
specific to Sullivan County and there
seemed to be the budding of heads
between the assessors and the
and the town
um
I'm adverse to
changing rsas
based on a single situation where I
think Sullivan County may want to
um
Go a different course of action rather
than attempting to change the rsas that
would apply to the entire
the entire state so I I would rise in in
support of the itel motion
representative
thank you Mr chair
um one of the other things that came up
in the discussion and the testimony was
the fact that many of New Hampshire's
Counties have adopted bylaws that govern
their operations
um Sullivan County does not seem to have
bylaws but bylaws would permit
County Commissioners and delegations
working together to conduct business in
all kinds of ways that is not
specifically outlined in the rsas but
would give them much more flexibility
and obviate the need for them to come to
us for permission to do these things and
to change the RSA so I'm complete
for the discussion seeing none clerk
would you call a role please
Vice chairman power yes
click votes yes
yes
representative Kelly
representative Allwood yes
representative Brown yes representative
Cahill yes
Representatives Davis yes
representative Tatro
yes
representative Trey Levin
no
representative Gilman yes
representative brung yes
representative yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes and the
chairman
yes
Ito passes 18-2
thank you Mr clerk
um
any opposition to this going on to the
I see none it will go on a consent
calendar represents Davis will be
assuming
you will do the committee report thank
you that closes the executive session on
HB 80.
and with that we will open up our last
bill to be exact today HP 148
representative power do you have a
motion thank you Mr chairman yes I have
a motion on House Bill 148 and that is
inexpedient to legislate
thank you representative power do we
have a second I second that motion
representative Cahill seconds the motion
representative power would you like to
speak to your motion yes thank you Mr
chair
so during the hearing unfortunately the
prime sponsor was not present to
introduce the bill as a result the bill
was introduced ad hoc
additionally
um
their was an individual
that was
supposed to be present to speak to the
bill from Rockingham County their
administrator and he also did not show
up
witnesses that it is it is optional but
the point being is that there was a lack
of input and the ability for this
committee to ask questions
and in my mind therefore this committee
cannot make an informed recommendation
based on what transpired at the hearing
thank you representative power further
discussion representative manager Puti
thank you Mr chair
again I did get a response from our
County Hillsborough County and it is one
of the issues that the county is facing
when it is
5000 is the ceiling to raise it to the
10 000 will make the bidding or purchase
on basic necessity for a large County
like Hillsboro uh would be helpful to
raise that so that they're not losing
competitive bidders because people are
not interested in waiting for the
bidding so I would
say I understand that there was no
presentation no questioning so I see the
reasoning uh but I would vote against
itl
for the discussion representative
thank you Mr chair
um and I am in concurrence with uh
representative power
on on this matter that um the prime
sponsor was not here to provide us with
sufficient information to to reach an
informed decision and also note that it
is the tradition we try to maintain this
tradition when possible in this
Committee of not changing the rsa's
foreign
shall I tell them that you rolled your
eyes when you saw my raised hand or
no I'm so glad that you laughed Mr chair
thank you very much I want to come yes
absolutely we must I want to make two
comments one is in regards to the
absence of the representative
um someone said he wasn't feeling well
and then I saw him later in the day
didn't get a chance to speak to him the
representative I don't know what
happened to the county representative
who was supposed to come talk to us
um yet I do also realize that all these
people that we're dealing with are just
people they're human beings stuff
happens the second thing I want to say
is like the other Bill we discussed I
think we need to come into the at least
the 20th century in regards to how much
things cost and we all know I filled up
my gas tank today I won't tell you how
much I put in
um so I will not be voting in favor of
the itl thank you
thank you for the comments
representative Gallagher
um so
well uh
the
while the prime sponsor might not have
been here in the Rockingham County
official might not have been here
um I was just rechecking my notes and it
looks like
um Derek ferland who from Sullivan
County
um who was testifying on all of the
other bills gave testimony on this one
as well so it's not like we had no
testimony on it we we did have some just
not from
the people that we were hoping it would
be from
um so yeah um I I think regardless from
that
[Music]
um
it's
I'm probably going to join the
um itl vote but um
it it's not because we didn't have any
testimony it's just that the testimony
thank you representative any further
discussion
itlhb 148.
Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie
collect votes yes representative
representative yourkella yes
representative Kelly
representative Allwood yes
representative Brown yes
representative Cahill yes
Representatives Davis yes
representative Tatro
representative Trey Levin
no
representative Gilman no
representative wrong
yes
representative mangaputi yes
representative Gallagher
uh yes representative Hicks yes
representative howling yes
representative priest yes and the
chairman yes
motion for itl passes 18 to 2.
thank you Mr clerk any opposition to
seeing none it will go on to the consent
calendar calendar representative power
will write the committee report
and that closes the executive session on
148.
all right
um we are scheduled to return here at 1
30 to take up for four house bills so we
uh if you wish to speak you'll need to
fill out a pink card those are up on the
what's that
by the clipboard uh for the bill
um
if during any of the hearings somebody
wants to put a pink card do not bring
them up here put them over on that table
or bring them to representative Brown he
is the collector of those and he will
he's going to introduce the last bill
from Ashley Laurie okay yeah I thought
you talked with me last night about that
so okay very good
okay we're going to get going here it's
uh 1 30. I'm gonna open up the uh public
hearing on HP 44 relative to permissible
I assume I am looking at rep McWilliams
very good it's yours your floor thank
you so much Mr chair I'm going to
co-present with a former representative
Ivy band just for the record it'll be
both of us
um my name is representative Rebecca
McWilliams I represent South Concord I'm
a mom of could you do me a favor pull
that mic a little closer to thank you
absolutely I'm a mom of three I hope
that all three of my children will one
day grow up to live in New Hampshire and
I think housing is probably the most
important thing we're talking about for
my generation so this bill is for my
kids and also for me
um and uh just want to make things very
clear there should be an amendment that
all of you should have had passed out
the top of the page says
uh January 12 2023
2023-0029h please make sure you're
looking at the amendment that's what I'd
like to speak to today it's a proposed
amendment just to clarify a couple
things slightly slightly different than
the initial bill as filed
so let me know if you don't have that
I've got extras and there's some on the
table as well all right so let's talk
about how spill 44. this is a reprise
we've seen this bill before in front of
this committee and we've actually passed
it out of this committee on a bipartisan
fashion previously it's back
um the intention of this bill is very
simple we are trying to do a Statewide
fix to resolve an issue that seems to
have crept into many of our local
Municipal zoning authorities
and so what I'm saying is we have
restricted our zoning as a state in a in
a blanket statement we have restricted
our zoning so that single family is
pretty much the rule of the land and in
many instances that is hurting us for
having more housing and more units in
existing buildings because we aren't
able to break down an existing building
from a single family into up to four
units so this is a Statewide fix to what
I see as too much over regulation at the
municipal level for the past 25 years or
so
so we call this bill affectionately a
fourplex is a house
meaning if you can have a single family
residential house in some of the areas
we're going to talk about you can also
split it up into a fourplex with all
kinds of asterisks and caveats but big
picture think fourplex is a house when
you think house bill 44.
so what does this mean
what we're looking at is about 37
percent of all municipalities in the
state so this is only impacting a third
of the state and then when we talk about
land area it's actually much much less
than a third of the state because really
this bill is only about areas that
actually have Municipal Water and Sewer
so if you live in a town that has
Municipal Water and Sewer it may only be
to the downtown it may only be the Main
Street and a couple of side streets that
extend off of that that is the area that
is impacted by this fourplex is a house
Statewide bill
so if you live in a rural area and you
don't have a municipal County a
Municipal Water and Sewer you need both
then this bill does not impact you or
your constituents at all it is simply
those areas that have Municipal Water
and Sewer will be held to the standard
allowing you to take an existing
building that would typically just be a
single family and split it up into four
units a couple other caveats in addition
to having to have Municipal Water and
Sewer you also need to meet state code
so if you would be subject to having to
do a sprinkler system in your multi-unit
building you still have to do that you
can't get away with that you must
sprinkle your building
parking parking is huge parking still
applies and that's the reason that I
made sure that we rewrote this amendment
to super super clarify
if you have a parking requirement for
your municipality that says you need to
have a certain number of spaces for a
certain number of bedrooms that still
applies this bill does not get around
parking minimums
same thing with side yard and front yard
setbacks they still apply you can't
expand your footprint or build something
bigger on an empty lot that's within a
Municipal Water and Sewer District you
can only build what you would normally
be able to build but a fourplex is a
house so I'm going to turn this over to
Ivy band add a little bit more to what I
just explained can you pass this out
excuse me before uh
I know
the honor roll Ivy van was a rep are is
she still around no
I am not okay
um
actually we have pink cards up here
we're going to go in the order of pink
cards uh did you fill out a pin card oh
yes I will have you speak after uh the
other individuals
um
there's not enough but Rebecca's gonna
pass out
um some precedent Gallery photographs of
what we're talking about when we talk
about duplexes triples and quads I'm
sorry to say that my printer is not fast
enough to produce one for everyone on
the committee but there's a bunch of
them and you can share them
all right so before I give up the
microphone
I'm of course happy to answer any
questions and the handout is really
helpful for visual people like myself
I'm an architect this picture's worth a
thousand words
um just looking at some of the potential
housing types that could
uh be infill in some of these missing
teeth lots that are serviced by
Municipal Water and Sewer still have to
meet the side yard setbacks still need
to meet fire protection still need to
beat parking but you could have four
units so
thank you uh Mr chairman good afternoon
and thanks for taking my question
I come with a from a small community
where we have a small uh water
wastewater treatment plant and also
small water system
and we have a master plan so we know in
so many years we're going to have to put
up a new treatment plant
if this was to pass you would probably
cost a ton of wolf ball between 50 and
100 million dollars because we have to
expand our wastewater treatment plan how
can I justify that to the to the people
that I represent
so you're talking about having existing
Municipal Water in Wolfeboro and also
the and there are some empty lots that
are serviced by this existing municipal
water and some houses who could be
subdivided within that area and so the
demand would increase on your existing
Municipal Water tremendous you know also
on the the treatment of the uh yeah the
septic absolutely and I believe your
taxes would also increase on each of
those units and the newly developed Lots
correct
I don't know if they'd increase to will
we spending 50 to 100 million dollars to
accommodate that would would balance out
that's an excellent question and um I'm
not going to be able to do a bunch of
math and kind of throw numbers at you
but I think it's worth analyzing a big
picture of course the intention here is
to build more housing in New Hampshire
because we are desperate for more
housing in New Hampshire and if build
more housing means subdivide an existing
house that could turn into up to four
units then that's the intention of the
Bill of course that will increase the
amount of waste coming from the building
and the demand for water coming from the
building but that's sort of the
direction the state needs to go because
we haven't for so long we have pent-up
representative uh power
thank you Mr chairman good afternoon and
thank you for taking my question so
clearly this bill
um
involves single-family Lots on which all
the setbacks will still pertain
so my question and it's to allow on that
single family lot
additional units to be built so the
question is is with regards to like say
for example you want to put four units
on the single family lot is how do we
deal with or is this something already
in local ordinances with regards to the
setbacks between the units
do you understand the question well I I
meant spacing between I
I do understand the question
so
it depends on the size of the lot what
you're envisioning is probably a two to
five acre lot with four tiny houses
that's probably the image you have in
your mind but when I'm talking about
downtown lots that have Municipal Water
and Sewer they're probably more like a
half acre maybe one acre lots so really
what we're envisioning is a single
structure that has party walls if it's a
duplex it's just got a vertical or
horizontal party wall so it's fire rated
between the two units if one of them
burns down the other hopefully doesn't
so it's not really about the setback
between units however for those downtown
lots that are served by Municipal Water
and Sewer and do have the acreage to
support individual buildings we would
look to the municipalities requirements
for distance between the buildings so
those are still valid there's no change
from this legislation to the municipal
rules for setbacks between units on one
lot
foreign
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
isn't this very similar to what we used
to have back in the days double triple
Decker where multi-family homes lived in
a small lot with before the car parking
uh thing raised how would it impact or
in a positive way or negative way for
communities which is livable walkable
communities live work and play in the
same area kind of thing that reduces the
need for car
how would it impact or enhance a
community's vibrancy
all right I'm seeing two parts to the
question the first part is the history
of multi-family in New Hampshire New
Hampshire much like the rest of New
England started to adopt parking
minimums and single-family zoning
mid-century last century and that really
reduced
the tools available in our toolkit it
reduced our ability to develop
multi-family because of zoning that
prevented multi-family from being built
so historically we have some really
beautiful downtowns across the state
that have I'm just going to describe an
example some beautiful old Victorian
buildings that when they were built in
the early 1900s were either rooming
houses or an in a really big square
footage and and over the years they've
been adapted and often turn into
multiple units for dwelling we have
those buildings
right now if a building like that occurs
and is not grandfathered which okay it
does happen it's in single-family zoning
it still needs to be occupied by a
single family unless someone goes for a
variance within the municipality it's
arduous it's expensive it's hard to do
that process this would take that
existing gorgeous Victorian that you're
stuck with as a single family and allow
you to partition off the third floor in
the Attic as a unit provided you meet
the parking requirements the setback
fire protection it just allows someone
who already owns that building to do
what the intention was for that building
all along when it was first built but
we're now in this pickle where we've
just constrained ourselves with Zoning
for the last 25 years that we are
bursting at the seams with desire for
more housing so this is in response to
that that was number one the history
number two in terms of parking once
again we are talking about
city sewer City Water generally downtown
areas so some of the nice amenities that
we have in downtowns already attract
younger people to want to be within
walking distance to the cafe coffee the
bar drinks you want to be able to walk
home from both of those generally if
you're choosing to live in a downtown
area
so while our parking requirements still
apply
you could choose not to use a car and to
be much more walkable because it's in
that area and that's generally what
we're incentivizing in our beautiful
representative Guthrie
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
your effort in this area
uh I have uh really two questions if I
could first one is do you think that 70
percent of our communities are right in
the legislating that the 30 percent that
may not want this zoning has to
well isn't that the conundrum of being a
legislator right we we're reps we're
elected to make rules for the entire
State and that's what we do in order to
solve big problems right I wouldn't be
bringing this before you if it wasn't a
big problem and it's looking for a
solution that's been caused by
individual municipalities becoming
nimby's saying not in my backyard I
don't want to have multiple units in my
town
so here we are starving for housing and
we've we've legislated ourselves into a
corner by local law creating these
single-family zoning districts that we
have the services to do more with that
in terms of infrastructure we absolutely
could do more with and in terms of
walkability stumble home from the bar
distance it's the right spot to do it
and yet here we are it's been 25 years
of fighting this battle something's got
to give so I hear what you're saying
about the majority forcing something on
the minority but that's part of being a
politician is solving a really difficult
problem and certainly this has become a
difficult problem follow up Mr chairman
I think our responsibility is religious
ladies would you wouldn't you believe
that it's more to follow the majority
not the minority I just as a side I live
in a community that doesn't have water
it doesn't have sewage we're not going
to be affected by this at all and I I
like this idea
I'm just really concerned and I don't
know what you can do to help me when you
say that this bill says shall and once I
see that word
as a legislator
I feel that the real concern as to what
that shall
requires and what the unintended
consequences are thank you thank you for
your effort thank you any further to
humans
representative Holland thank you Mr
chair I have a theoretic clarifying
question for you so suppose I have a
one-story Ranch on a half acre lot
that's in a residential Zone under this
legislation would I have to then it's
really pretty hard to cut up that one
floor Ranch do I expand that into
another uh larger you know multi-unit
setup or would I be allowed to add a
detached you know from this list another
unit on the lot as long as it met all
the setback and height requirements
that's the beauty of this legislation it
leaves it up to your local
municipalities requirements so you would
look to whatever your municipality says
for that lot for those setbacks for
whether or not you can have a detached
Adu not every town allows that but if
everybody around the table if you have
your mics on please turn them off
because it reduces the uh the pickup on
representative priests
uh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question uh
isn't it true that this isn't you're not
mandating that every
single family Victorian house be
converted into four structures but if
the property owner who has that house
wants to opt into that provision he has
as long as he meets the parking
requirements rights and parking setbacks
and all that yes right you're not
forcing this on this does not force
development right thank you
use your mic representative Brown thank
you
you know you had to shut them off so
I'm just trying to make sure that I
understand this permit by right means
that the landowner has the right to do
this work
as long as it conforms with all the
other zoning requirements without
getting special approval from the towns
Okay so
so that just follow up there this is the
question so that requires
sorry that requires
the town to approve this regardless of
whether they want multi-family homes in
a certain area of their Community is
there's no approval process it's by
right right but it would need to happen
if a developer
is in Municipal Water and Sewer meets
the parking meets the setbacks has an
existing building they'd like to
subdivide they can sprinkler it
there's no variance process by the
municipality it goes through they still
need a building permit so the
municipality would have to give the
permit provided all the permit
representative Gallagher
um so
just uh clarifying point about
um legislative history so you mentioned
the bill coming out of
um our committee last term on a
bipartisan basis but um I don't I I
didn't quite catch whether you included
the number or not but just to confirm
this was um House Bill 1177 last term
right
representative Brown
so I just want to make sure this right
so based on what this legislation does
it
basically requires the town to allow
this development because the landlord
Lando is requesting if it meets all the
other
Town requirements is that correct that
are already existing
so you've got a landowner who owns a lot
downtown Municipal Water and Sewer they
have Architects plans for a four unit
building it's a small lot so it's going
to be tall it meets the height
requirements it meets all the
requirements but it's multiple units the
town would have to say yes to a building
permit for that there's no additional
appeal variance process that would
prevent this from happening
representative Guthrie
thank you and thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking additional
questions
we talked about unintended consequences
is it possible that one of those
unintended consequences would be the
delay
um a rejection of communities putting in
water and sewage like the previous
question said that they had the water
but they didn't have the sewage wouldn't
that just discourage that Community from
putting a surgeon and then buying into
this
I understand the question you're asking
I think that there's a calculus that
needs to be done on the value of the
increase in taxes for multiple units
versus single family and it really
depends on how each of those
municipalities calculates the long-term
benefit for increase in taxes versus the
long-term cost for adding water and or
sewer or both so this is at the local
level making that decision about their
10-year plan where they will extend
Water and Sewer
they will also have to take into that
math what the value is of the taxes of a
multi-unit and that's not saying it will
happen just that it could so there's a
percentage of developable lots that's
the math that would need to be
considered to make that decision
I think thank you for your question it's
always nice to hear them thank you
chairman representative welcome
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um
in my town we recently had a major fire
where our water system couldn't maintain
water pressure to fight that fire
um our water system isn't capable of
supporting
more infrastructure like this like if
this was passed it would impact Us and
how do you how do you propose we deal
with that consequence if that if this
passes
and we have that problem
that's a really tough situation because
you know you don't have the pressure
right now to respond to another fire
right so you're kind of in an emergency
situation you're responding you're
figuring out next steps right
regardless of whether or not this bill
passes I think you're kind of in a
situation where you need to make a
decision about long-term bonding for
your water
because you have a potential another
fire you're gonna have people who get
rejected for insurance if they can't
fight fires in your town that's like
that's a very specific concern and it's
legitimate but I think you're probably
going to have to do some kind of major
monetary investment in order to address
representative Cahill go ahead
if you give everyone the right to do
that which would give them the right to
do this
it would force us into even more of an
emergency situation if if suddenly a lot
of people exercise their right
so I mentioned insurance I think it's
important that we talk about the market
that we're in right now if you have
someone who sees these vacant Lots you
had a big fire they're probably some
empty lots downtown with water and sewer
right now developers sees those lots
considers putting in multi-family if
they can't get the insurance because you
don't have the water pressure they can't
sell those units so it's a chicken and
egg issue where it's not a salable
building if you can't get insurance to
protect against future fire right so I
see the concern but the reality of the
market is if you can't get insurance for
a building you're trying to put in
there's no there's no one you can sell
it to because they need to get a
mortgage and the bank requires Insurance
even if they want to hold it privately
with a cash cash purchase they still
want insurance for the building so the
inability to ensure that basically puts
thank you you're welcome
uh representative lasalles
yes thank you uh Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question
um could it be that a local planning
board that's in the situation my friend
from Raymond is in where the town as a
whole is underserved
uh by the current infrastructure
could a local planning board say well
we're already in a bind here
so we're not going to allow any more uh
of this sort of thing because it says if
it's served by
could you make could a local planning
board make the argument that
in that case you're not being currently
this is such a very specific question
okay and I want to I want to give it the
Nuance that it deserves
so you're talking about a major fire
empty lot there was a water and sewer
hookup on the lot we know that the water
can't meet the Demand right now and so
the question is is it quote unquote
legally served I think you probably
would end up tied up in litigation about
that between the developer and the town
to determine whether or not it's served
it's sort of a question for a judge on
that one and so if the real question is
is there a way for the town to delay
multi-family development while
addressing the water yes the answer is
the courts
you're welcome
representative manager Puti thank you Mr
chair thank you representative for
taking another question from me isn't it
true that currently
the number of bathrooms in a single
family home
determines the tax for that family home
so if you're adding four units adding
more bathrooms so the tax would go up so
that's a revenue to the city or the
municipality
I don't have an answer to that I think
it's Town specific and I'm also not an
expert on how taxes are set based on
square footage bedrooms
toilet rooms it really depends so I
Russian Howell and I think you have your
finger up thank you Mr chair and thanks
for taking my question so I'll give you
another theoretical I'm an investor I
come into your town I come back to that
that ranch on the half acre lot of my
incentive would be to probably demolish
that house build four luxury townhouses
specifically because if it's served by
water and sewer and it's walkable to my
downtown its value is really great so
while it is adding housing it's really
not chipping away at the diverse housing
or affordable housing is that a concern
so at this point in New Hampshire any
housing is good housing and we can have
a long discussion about how building new
units causes people to jump from their
existing units to the new units and it
frees up those existing units to more
affordable buyers or renters but big
picture you're increasing your tax base
from going from a single family ranch to
four townhouses so you're getting more
revenue on the municipal side
and you're getting a probably more
diverse renter owner for each of those
units as opposed to single family right
people who live in townhouses aren't
necessarily the same people who live in
raised ranches I'm speaking in Gross
generalities here but just to give you a
sense in many of our towns we have
concerns about where folks who are ready
to be empty nesters can go so providing
four new townhouses could be the hottest
representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
like my colleague over here I'll give
you a hypothetical if I if I take a
single family with two children living
it and I convert it to a four family
with eight children living in it there's
still only one tax bill
there's one piece of property getting
taxed and I'm possibly adding more tax
burden by adding
more Demand on the school system
so I'm not increasing the taxes as much
as adding the cost to to teach those
students you know those potential
students
I'm
do you see
how that is a potential cost
for the taxpayers
I like our hypothetical
if they're condos they're individually
taxed if they're one building with four
units with one owner that's renting four
units it's taxed as just one building so
it depends on the way it's built so yes
no to the way it's taxed but I like your
question
I think we could probably have a whole
separate conversation about schools and
the cost of education for young people
in our state I will tell you that
statistically we are reducing the number
of students significantly year over year
in our schools we're on a downward trend
and part of that has to do with this
conundrum that we don't have housing
so we as government officials are
talking about correcting the market
because we need to because we don't have
housing for the Next Generation so I
absolutely like the question about the
cost of education and I I see where
you're going with that but the flip side
is if we don't have any houses at all
for people who have young kids they'll
choose not to be in that Community
altogether and you'll keep seeing
representative Hicks
thank you Mr chair thank you for uh
taking the question
so there's been a few questions about
infrastructure demands if this is to
pass
um could you speak briefly please about
uh traffic impacts in neighborhoods say
the south end of Concord for example
great question
so
I want to emphasize the reason I
presented this amendment today is
because it emphasizes parking right the
parking requirements are the same as
they have always been and so when we
design infrastructure and we set parking
requirements in our local zoning it's
making sure in addition to congestion
and too many cars on the road issues is
making sure that it's possible to park
the cars
so we've already got a mechanism in
place to protect against increases major
increases in traffic
Concord is an interesting spot because
when we talk about downtown Concord much
of the units that we're allowing in
downtown Concord actually have street
parking and that's part of our zoning
so not to go too far afield but if we
have a requirement for two parking
spaces on the lot and an allowance for
two parking spaces on the street that
doesn't change with this bill that's
still the same allowance and therefore
for those people uh who plan on speaking
on this just so you know we have a very
long list we are going to put in a three
minute time limit so make sure your
testimony is within that three minutes
we will not we will be giving you a 30
second warning and that's going to be it
we have a lot of speakers in fact we've
had you up here very long I have two
quick questions for you myself and then
could you uh just tell me uh in line
five it talks about res residential
zoning why wouldn't this apply to
foreign
the power is granted under this
subdivision the local legislative body
of a city town or county in which there
are located unincorporated towns or
unorganized places shall allow as a
matter of right any single-family lot in
a residential zoning District served by
Municipal Water and Sewer so we're
talking about single-family Lots
residential zoning District
I'm not familiar with the code that has
single-family lots and Commercial
districts but if that is the case I
understand that generally in commercial
you can still do Residential in a lot of
our zoning ordinances it's just
considered a lesser use
but we're talking about single-family
lot zoning so really this is intended to
address some of those missing teeth
within the urban fabric whereas on
Commercial generally we're talking much
bigger buildings much bigger tenants so
I'm not saying you can't do infill with
multi-family within a commercially zoned
area but often towns have a really good
reason why they've zoned an area
commercial and they see that as a
business district so introducing
multi-family into the business district
may not meet the tax structure needs of
the municipality in the way that they
set up their local planning
that the other question I have is
um
why only two uh
single-family lots and water and sewer
let's as we have talked about examples
let's say we you own a four acre lot
that's in a residential district not
served by
Water and Sewer yet you have the
capacity for a well and septic system
that would support a four unit why is
that not included
um the intent of this bill was to strike
a balance between the rural character of
many of our towns that have those four
acre lots and would prefer to keep it
much more Farmhouse trees Fields rather
than downtown walkable Municipal Water
and Sewer served areas thank you you're
welcome
I I would like to let some of the other
people testify and I'm happy to speak
with folks offline we are going to move
on to the next uh testifier we have
hello uh thank you for the privilege of
speaking here today
um
I'm I represent Stratford District 17
which is in Dover New Hampshire
and I am semi-retired from the business
of building
and renovating residential homes and
I've worked as my husband in the
Seacoast for the last 12 years
most of the work has been building
single-family homes
if we built a house on speculation and
we're lucky enough to find a lot that's
it was usually the only option we had to
build
um and then it had to be a big one
usually in order to cover the expense of
the lot
so
that was in a way prohibitive against
building an affordable house for many
people
but our last project that we finished in
Dover this past August was to build a
duplex close to downtown Dover
on a property that with an existing
house that we rent out
it isn't what Dover calls the urban
density
multi-residential District the house had
a large lot that could accommodate a
duplex
so it's similar to what we are proposing
might happen with this bill
um we built to play the duplex that
already fit within the setbacks and
other requirements of the city
but we had to apply through a special
zoning board of appeals for a special
exemption in order to do this conversion
and I would say we're able to rent both
units before we had even finished
construction
within 12 hours of posting the ad that
is how crazy the demand is for housing
in our area
um
and there are a lot of new apartment
buildings being built in the Central
District part of Dover
most of them have units that are much
more expensive than what we were able to
build
and most of them because they're large
are being built by out-of-state
contractors
and I have the impression not 100 sure
that most of that rent is also going out
of the state
so we applaud the city of Dover for
allowing these conversions and allowing
accessory dwelling units
in most of their districts
but not all of our neighboring towns are
allowing this they would prefer to keep
single family zoning
and expect the people that work in their
Town work in their restaurants and shops
who are caring for their elderly
who are working in their schools in the
police departments to keep driving in
from other towns so that affects traffic
and
um
and there's owning prohibits the
creation of affordable housing within
their town
and it's really not the best solution
for our whole area sorry I'll try to rip
it up you need to wrap it up please okay
thank you but what one town does affects
all of the other municipalities around
it in terms of their housing uh crisis
in the and demand
um every town is land that can be used
for urban or Village infill and there
are many lots that could accommodate
more housing and still meet the
guidelines
I just want to make one comment about
um fees the impact on sewer and water
many people end over including city
employees were shocked at the fees that
we paid to build two units we paid forty
two thousand dollars just in Impact fees
but it will raise money to cover sewer
and water
okay thank you thank you very much any
questions
representative Gallagher um
so yeah that sounded like testimony in
favor of the bill but I don't think I
quite heard an explicit I'm in favor of
this bill or not could I yes I'm very
representative Guthrie
thank you again Mr chair and just one
quick question uh has there been any
success you said to Dover
allows uh some maybe different house
housing rules and regulations and others
has there been any success in proposing
to the 30 percent of the communities
that have sewer and water so many been
any success in asking them as individual
towns to accept this proposal
I haven't been involved in asking other
towns what to accept
um I would
I would like to see the city of Dover
make the process a little easier
um and and
reduce some of the restrictions that
were put on us to build it but we still
were able to build it yeah follow up Mr
chairman if yes I could uh do you think
it's a better approach is to ask every
community that might qualify whether
they have water or sewer or not what do
that they would accept this kind of a
proposal
yes thank you okay representative kale
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question I heard you mentioned impact
fees and your 47 000 impact fee
um actually it was a total amount of
fees it wasn't just impact but when we
added all the fees that was yeah
in this bill if it gives everyone the
right to do this to the impact fees go
away or would they still be there
so you know further questions thank you
very much call Representative Josh
yokella
I'm going to remind everybody three
thank you and uh for the record my name
is Joshua okella uh representing
Rockingham 32 Fremont Danville and
Brentwood
um I'm also on the housing special
commission or special committee on
housing and so I definitely think that
this is
um a uh important issue that that we
need to consider these um
different options especially because
it's my contention that the the
government has been putting its thumb on
the scale of reducing housing for a long
time and I see this as a way of reducing
the pressure of that thumb on the scale
that is reducing the housing in in our
state and
um also I wanted to
um
bring to mind a a thought that uh is one
of the benefits of this this uh
legislation is that
um the cost of producing
um
uh like a mile of
of uh sewer and water is essentially a
fixed cost and so if you can have uh
divide that cost by a higher number of
people than you one would not have to
build that second mile if you need to
serve let's say 200 people you might
only need that one mile instead of
having to build that second mile so then
there would be
um A reduced cost as far as
infrastructure build out because while
you're may have to have a larger pipe or
whatever you don't have to go for that
second mile of pipe and so
there is a value in in the
municipalities
uh perspective as far as not having to
build as much infrastructure
and therefore having more green space if
you have if that is one of your goals
but also from the um the homeowner's
perspective that
um you know
divided that uh you know like like say a
hundred feet of Road Frontage
correlates to a certain amount of taxes
and if that's divided up by four and
that now you have less taxes per
individual on that that road so I think
it's a win-win for both uh reducing
overall requirements for infrastructure
allowing more uh densely populated areas
that were already meant to be densely
populated by
by being in these downtown areas and
allowing for more green open space areas
um because there is just only a certain
number of people and so if you put them
all in one spot then there's less and so
I just wanted to throw those those ideas
out so that you can think about them
when you're considering the bill so
thank you very much thank you
representative
representative Guthrie
I hate to monopolize them sorry Mr
chairman it's a very important issue uh
could it be possible particularly where
you're on the housing subcommittee to
get a list of all the communities that
so
I mean it's possible to get the
communities like say the towns that have
uh sewer and water
um but even if I gave you that list
there would be a subset of those because
not all of those might be serviced the
entire town right so are you looking for
just the communities that would be
affected or like the number of units
within a community that would be
affected by the legislation as long as
you refer to it as to what it is I am
I'm just looking to see how big of an
impact this would have on the state as a
whole
oh if if that uh I just want I can I can
look at it now more for the housing
group that you're on yeah and I'm sorry
to bring it up at this good stage yeah
we could have it be available uh I think
it'd be uh
piece of information it would be
worthwhile I appreciate the information
that we've already got so thank you
representative
thank you Mr chair I believe the um the
first Speaker the sponsor of the bill
um gave that statistic
well 38 percent I know that she said
that she didn't list out the
municipalities but but we have a rough
statistic of 38 38 of municipality or 36
37 of of municipalities but if you would
like a list of the names of the
municipalities that's one thing if you
wanted like the like I just wanted to be
clear about what the question was so
thank you I believe that was Alyssa he
was asking for so we'll look for a list
from you guys at some point for that
sure seeing no more questions thank you
for your testimony representative
yokello call Representative Julie uh
Gilman
foreign
thank you Mr chair and thank you
committee for listening to my testimony
for the record I'm representative Julie
Gilman I represent Rockingham District
11 comprising the town of Exeter I'm
just going to go through some bullet
points really quick because I know there
are other people who want to speak
I would like to bring the committee to
recall yesterday we heard a few bills
about the cost of rent for for
um
affordable units work Workforce units
whatever name you want to give them and
the people who are against those bills
all said we need more units more units
more units we need more places for
people to live
I would like to also
I think in response to one of
Representative Guthrie's questions is
that we are not
um
clamping down Statewide on any any
zoning laws we are actually expanding
property rights by letting single-family
property owners
have some income and bring up the value
and I think the last thing I like to say
is on the remote sign-in sheet the
commentary we have several PDFs and and
texts from uh many uh residents well
many many uh from all over the state and
there are 80 in support of this bill and
for a post
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Gilman for taking my
question uh wouldn't this allow a person
like me to age in place instead of
staying in my single family home or
selling it and moving to a downsizing if
I can convert my
single family home into multi-family
at least I can entice my next Generation
to come live back or at least share the
home with others younger than me
absolutely
seeing no more questions thank you
representative
uh next the we will call the honorable
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
members of the municipal and County
government it's nice to see you all
again
so I'm here to talk as I do all the time
about why a fourplex is a house and why
we should consider it one what the
fourplex Bill does is say as everyone
before me has said it allows up to four
units it doesn't require four units it
allows up to four on any lot served by
Municipal Water and Sewer there was a
question about well what if we don't
have enough Municipal Water in sewer
your planning department has the ability
to turn down applications if you do not
have adequate capacity so you don't have
to worry about being forced to do
anything I just want to make that clear
so this bill doesn't prohibit building a
single-family house in any of these
neighborhoods it just adds more choices
we're really short of Housing and we're
particularly short of housing in the
places that people want to live
according to the AARP a pretty
mainstream Community
62 percent of people would like to live
in a place that is walkable that's a
neighborhood where they can walk to buy
a quart of milk let their kid ride their
bicycle to buy a popsicle and get home
before it melts and in the immortal
words of my daughter Lily stumble home
from the bar
[Music]
those places are places served if there
is water and sewer those are the places
that have water and sewer are they close
in neighborhoods so what this bill does
is allow those neighborhoods to develop
in the way that they would have done 50
years ago if you look at any
neighborhood in New Hampshire or any
place in the United States and I forgot
to tell you this but this is what I do
for a living is I talk to I work as a
municipal planner and this is an issue
that's a problem everywhere
um
so these places are places where we want
to see infill we want to see gradual
adding of units somebody said well what
if an out of town developer fourplexes
are not a product that's going to bring
the Toll Brothers Homes to your
neighborhood these buildings are built
typically by two women in a pickup truck
three guys and a dog with a van they're
not big outfit jobs often they're rehabs
of existing buildings that are currently
occupied by two little old people who
can barely pay the taxes never mind
maintain it so this bill would help
people who are looking for houses
by creating more units and creating them
where people want to live it helps
people who are in houses that are too
big for them it helps municipalities
when we put more units in existing
neighborhoods we get better use of our
infrastructure it costs I know you all
have heard me say this it costs 4.65
central line foot to salt sand plow
ditch and mow a foot of town maintained
Road in the state of New Hampshire
more units
makes that cost more bearable
and why is it a fourplex that we settled
on two reasons fourplexes are house
sized and therefore will fit into
existing neighborhoods also
you can get a beige mortgage for a
fourplex FHA Freddie Mac Fannie Mae all
of those products will give you a beige
mortgage for a fourplex it's just a
house
this bill does not change anything that
the local jurisdiction manages Now
parking lot size lot coverage setbacks
frontages Building height types if you
want to adopt design standards you can
adopt design standards
um
it improves if you could wrap it up
please yep sure pass you three minutes
um also I would remind anybody else
who's going to testify if you can keep
the testimony to unique original
language in other words let's not get
into repeating what's already been
stated right so the point here is that
this bill lets neighborhoods change in
the way that they would have changed 50
years ago these are tools that we used
to have in our toolboxes you used to be
able to do this you can't now this is
both a housing issue and a property
rights issue and I think it's crucial
that we adopt this at the state level
thank you very much and I'm happy to
take questions uh representative Brown
you have a question
yes thank you Mr chairman the question I
have actually two quick questions
um
the first one is
do these new multi-family homes
impact adjacent single family homes in a
negative way no there's plenty of
evidence that there is no detriment to
having multi-family next to single
family there's plenty of evidence that
it does quite the opposite because it
provides a bigger base for your local
the other point that you mentioned is
that uh
this legislation does not preclude the
planning board from approving
um from disapproving these for other
reasons absolutely yes because your
zoning code typically has rules about
how far from the side lot lines the
building can be how many parking places
you have how much percentage of the lot
you can cover with the building they may
have design standards you have to abide
by all of those and the amendment that
you received one of the reasons for that
amendment is it makes the adoption of
this bill 2024 which would give a
jurisdiction time to take a look at its
code and see if there's something that
they want to change before this takes
effect
thanks for your response thank you so
you know I've heard the questions thank
you very much uh next we are going to
uh also I'd remind everybody uh please
State whether you're for Against The
uh good afternoon I'm Michael Barrett
I'm the town planner for Durham New
Hampshire
um and I'm speaking for myself as a
professional Town planner although I
think many people in Durham would agree
with what I have to say
um I am personally very dedicated to the
housing issue I believe the state should
push me require municipalities to do
more I I believe that's important and
legitimate
um I am also a very strong supporter of
mixed use and mixed building types
single families duplexes what we call
missing middle row houses townhouses
triple Deckers Cottage courts you know
accessory Apartments all of this
um however what we think of as mixed-use
neighborhoods in Portsmouth Manchester
older places they work and they're
wonderful but there was a different way
that we built 50 and 100 years ago we
don't build that way anymore
unfortunately a lot of new construction
is is pretty awful and without character
so I am opposed to this bill I believe
something must be done we should move in
this direction but this bill is uh goes
very very far and very honestly I think
this could be very damaging
and I urge you to think very hard about
this I've been a professional planner
for 35 years I've been dealing with
design development zoning and I'm very
concerned about this and particularly
for communities like Durham where we are
wrestling with student housing and
single-family neighborhoods being very
very harmed by the hockey house you know
the even the women's volleyball team
taking over a house and we are
struggling to manage this as I'm sure
they are in Plymouth and Keene in
Manchester and other places so if we
have to accept four units that'll be
very damaging
um single families not sacrosanct
exclusionary zoning must be dealt with
but this is this is too much I urge you
to send it back for more work I would be
very happy to help with that
um imagine an old Street an old
neighborhood of of Bungalows say you
know 1920s relatively large Lots you
know third of an acre lots you are
forcing that Community to allow four
unit buildings in that neighborhood if
they have water and sewer so you are
going to see a developer maybe one of
the owners they'll say well I can't
really fit four units that's a lot of
that's a lot of bread I'm going to
scrape my Bungalow I'm going to build a
new four unit building and unfortunately
we've forgotten how to build attractive
buildings in this country
architecture most of us don't know how
to deal with that so what you're going
to see is a ugly four unit vinyl box and
not only that but it's typical to
require two parking spaces per unit
maybe one and a half it depends but so
you're going to see a big ugly vinyl box
with no character in a historic
neighborhood and probably eight parking
spaces now if those eight parking spaces
are in the front they're going to pave
their lot it's going to be all asphalt
it'll be atrocious hopefully they'll be
in the rear which is not so harmful for
the streetscape but people are still not
going to be happy to be looking out
their backyards at a sea of parking so
the people in that neighborhood who who
live in modest Bungalows are going to
say what happened how did this happen I
thought zoning was here to protect us we
need flexibility we need to push we need
to deal with housing but this is way too
much
plus the way the ordinance is written
it's one paragraph if you're going to do
something okay I mean there's so many
things you know can you can you add
density provision it doesn't say it just
says lot size design standards are very
tricky we don't even do design site
review for duplexes
um you know if you're going to do it
office of strategic initiatives should
develop model ordinances small towns
don't even have planners some have water
and sewer they have no idea how to do
deal with design issues it could be a
disaster and parking alone is just will
will ruin it
um so there's a lot that could be done
you know
um required designs we really do need
you to open it up so there's a lot that
could be done I urge you to send it back
I'd be happy to work with them make it
incremental like the old ad law Adu law
which is excellent thank you for your
testimony any questions
thank you very much for your testimony
uh next we're going to call uh
Darren winum win him
good afternoon my name is Darren winam
oh I live in the town of Exeter I'm an
economic development director have been
for over 20 years and uh pretty much
disagree with everything respectfully
that we just said
um I'm going to come out this from a
Workforce housing point of view this is
de facto Workforce housing that's what
you've but that's what this creates
we have a tremendous Workforce problem
in this state particularly in the
Seacoast nobody can find housing and I'm
talking nobody the larger companies are
talking about moving because they can't
find employees
this would help greatly right now what
we have is
some communities are doing things that
are progressive some are not a lot of
the communities that are next to my town
and other towns don't want to do this
they expect us to do it and house their
company's workers it's a tremendous
problem this is a very good bill it's
been kicked around for a long time I
think it's time to get this thing done
that's all I have to say thank you
thank you before you leave um
on your card it says town of Exeter I
I'm not representing a town of extra
just just an accident I've never filled
one of those out before I've just I have
an economic development consulting
company thank you very much that's fine
yeah
thank you Mr chair and H Grace for the
municipal Association we oppose this
bill we Advocate to preserve local
control and oppose Statewide zoning
mandates as you might imagine and have
seen on display today uh our communities
do disagree about appropriate responses
to questions like this one raises
um and therefore we think that the
legislature should leave that in the
hands of municipalities a number of you
asked specific questions today that I
did want to address
um representative McDonald uh gave a
scenario of a new wastewater treatment
facility
um and representative Cahill about a uh
a water system
um
pressure line and I think those really
go to capacity which is a question that
I believe
um representative lasalles brought up
um and in response to representative
LaSalle's question
um which was what is the meaning of the
term served the answer was that's
something that we decided by the courts
and would require litigation we
obviously don't want any municipalities
to have to go through litigation if at
all possible we would like clear laws to
be passed through the legislature that
everyone understands
um representative power who I know
stepped out of the room but she asked a
specific question that I believe relates
to
line seven and the term four single
units and it her question related to the
spacing between those those units
um
and
while it's possible that local rules May
apply
um it's also possible that this
legislation is written that would allow
a individual owning that property to
develop for single units would override
any sort of local regulation to that end
so there
is some complexity here that I don't
know an answer to
um and I believe that feeds into uh
representative Hicks question about
traffic and um planning for that which
again really relates back to
infrastructure and really the role of
the planning board in assisting the
municipality and planning forward and we
think that should be a local decision
not something decided here in Concord
and I'm happy to take any questions
thank you for a brief informative
one minute and 40 seconds you're welcome
Mr chair
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee for the record my name is
Chris Norwood I am the 2023 public
policy chair for the New Hampshire
Association of Realtors and we would
like to express our support of this bill
as we did similarly last year
um In fairness to time just a couple
items to touch upon to put numbers on
the housing crisis uh 2022 saw the
median home price in our state to be 440
thousand dollars that was 11 up of 2021
and six percent over uh 2020 so
compounding per year
uh the average rental price for a two
bedroom in our state right now is just
shy of sixteen hundred dollars which is
about increasing you know about five to
seven percent each of the last five
years so our view is is a supply uh
certainly helps to alleviate the problem
regardless of the unit type and
regardless of the location
um it was stated before we do view this
as a private property rights issue and I
do believe that there are homeowners who
have single family homes who
um have a zoning that is uh imposed on
them historically that I think that uh
they would appreciate some relief from
and I think it's worth noting that a lot
of the Municipal Water and Sewer the
reason why we have such restrictive
zoning historically has been because you
need
um it's a geometry problem when you go
to have a well radii and a septic system
where you don't have Municipal Water and
Sewer you need about you know an acre
and a half two acres to get that well
radii and uh and your septic system so
they don't overlap with one another but
when you're dealing with a more uh
densely populated densely packed area
where there is Municipal Water and Sewer
this is the type of uh development that
quite frankly we want and we need
so I think that homeowners would
appreciate the flexibility to decide for
themselves if they should be able to
expand and then lastly I just wanted to
touch upon uh one of the questions that
was raised relative to uh density and
the additional
um uh toll perhaps was the word used on
our school system and I would say that
there is a lack of correlation between
the student population and increasing of
taxes and I would also say that our
school population
if you look at the statistics over the
last 15 years we've seen a decline of
K-12 population of about 30 to 35
000 students on a Statewide basis so I I
respect that some municipalities have a
concern about additional students
entering their systems I would say that
the um the fear perhaps of that is not
as strong as the reality and I
appreciate you uh
hearing my testimony and happy to answer
two minutes 48 seconds oh awesome I can
do better I can do better
representative manage booty thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
the question is you said you're a public
policy for realtors association what is
the current status in our
date in terms of available
residential units needed versus
um
shortage
so thank you very much representative
for the question uh on the apartment
rental side vacancy is under one half of
one percent so a rounding error if you
will on the single family home side we
would see that the current days on
Market which is typically measured in
months is now 23 days I believe it was
in 2022 it is getting a little bit
longer as interest rates start to climb
but still we would argue a balanced
Market you need to see 90 to 180 days to
be balanced in favor of both buyer and
seller
um guest follow-up thank you how would
this impact in terms of building the
inventory in a shorter period
uh or this would take as long as any
other large development
thank you again for the question I I
think that it's going to be a a small
impact I don't Envision this is going to
bring 10 000 units online overnight this
still takes time it takes financing is
really the most challenging aspect in
today's economy but I think what allows
again it goes to that private property
rights where there's there's a home
owner out there who wants to get
additional income perhaps from a rental
they want to be able to grow their
family in place it's it's not too
dissimilar to the Adu bill which this
body thought was a positive thing a
but representative Guthrie are you
asking for a question yeah oh I'm sorry
I should have I turned on I did have a
question I do you believe that the
character of a community is determined
mainly by the zoning and if we change
the zoning in any Community we're going
to change the character of that to me
thank you representative for the
question
somewhat related I think that when you
talk about the character what are we
talking about are we talking about the
number of individuals in the community
as some other folks have testified
before there's architecture which may or
may not be spelled out in
um in in your zoning regs my father
always likes to say you can't regulate
taste right and we walk we all walk
around our neighborhoods and we know
people who uh we wish the house hadn't
been built but that may or may not be
something that we can we excuse me a
planning board or zoning board currently
regulates is the architectural design so
when I think about character there's
different ways to think about it but I
don't think increasing the number of
individuals living in a community uh is
is a is a negative impact to that
Community follow-up Mr chairman if I
could go ahead do you think uh not in my
um
not necessarily representative thank you
for the question depends what the knot
in my backyard is if we want another uh
you know if you wanted a a toxic waste
dump or something in your backyard yes I
can certainly respect why that why that
would be but I I don't think that
um housing is something that is in a
knot in my backyard is a bad thing I
think that all of us would say that our
communities the coffee shops that have
been mentioned before the manufacturers
everyone needs
um employment I myself work in the
commercial side of the real estate
industry and I can tell you my employers
who I work with they are finding it
harder and harder to find labor and the
labor is driving from farther and
farther away and they're just not
interested in locating here and so
there's an imbalance is there a perfect
solution no but I do think that this
bill is is a small step in the direction
to solving a portion of our housing
crisis thank you Floyd your answer thank
you Mr chairman so you know other
questions I have one quick question
based on the NIMBY statement um would
you say that the term NIMBY is
subjective
is subjective yeah
yes I believe so thank you thank you sir
representative Gallagher all right so
and kind of to follow up this line of
questions
um so um
are you familiar with the yes in my
backyard movement and if so would um
you are gimby for short would you say
this counts as a ymb bill
thank you representative for the
question I've heard of the phrase I
don't know enough about the definition
and I I think relative to both not and
yes in my backyard I I think the
question is is this something that our
communities and I said Community overall
as a state needs and that's housing and
I think that the answer is yes I think
uh I'll stay away from labeling bills
thank you for your testimony uh next
we're going to call thank you everyone
you're welcome uh bright uh Bryce Cowell
thanks
I'm going to remind you the three
minutes please
yep good afternoon if you see a giant
stack of papers it's just because I
printed out my one-page testimony uh so
I can pass it out at the end good
afternoon Mr chair and members of the
committee my name is Bryce cowwoo and I
live in Manchester where I'm a homeowner
in a wonderful single-family
neighborhood I also currently serve as
the chair of the Manchester planning
board although I'm here today in my
personal capacity my own personal
capacity I do not represent the board or
the city at this time instead of diving
deep into planning related statistics or
numerical arguments like some others
have done I want to keep things simple
and brief and talk about freedom
because House Bill 44
in its Essence is about reducing local
government overreach I find it rather
ironic that so many places in the Live
Free or Die state currently Place such
stringent limitations on what private
property owners can do in residential
zones
right now the city of Manchester is
dictating what I do with my own
single-family home property and
thousands of other Granite Staters in
other cities and towns across New
Hampshire have to deal with similar
burdensome government regulation
now I fully recognize and appreciate
that government regulation can be
important especially when it addresses
matters of public health and safety such
as preventing an industrial
manufacturing facility from being built
right next to an established
neighborhood or perhaps when someone as
mentioned earlier wants to build a new
home or fourplex in an area that doesn't
have the requisite Municipal
infrastructure but that doesn't really
apply here from my vantage point using
your own residentially zoned property in
a more flexible way hurts nobody and can
actually benefit Society by providing
more housing more taxpayers and more
folks to participate in the community
yet so many cities and towns are
actively stopping people from doing that
housebo 44 on the other hand doesn't
make anybody do anything this bill
expands freedom for people in our great
state by allowing more folks to do more
with their own private property so if
any members of this committee would like
to stand up in the future and claim that
you fight for Freedom that you defend
private property rights that you support
the free market and that you want to
reduce government regulation or that you
believe and Live Free or Die if any of
that applies to you then respectfully I
would suggest that you support this
legislation because that is exactly what
hb44 does so again I wanted to keep
things short and sweet so that concludes
my planned remarks thank you for your
time and although I am not representing
Manchester in an official capacity I can
answer questions related to our planning
or zoning thank you
thank you representative man chaputi
thank you I didn't realize you had a eye
on the side Mr chip
um currently Manchester uh like Nashua
has zoning ordinances and how would it
impact the downtown Nash sorry
Manchester if this passes yeah thank you
for your question representative I do
want to clarify something that was
stated earlier there was some emphasis
on downtown impacts um for towns and
cities across the state given that
Manchester is a relatively large city in
the state this impact wouldn't really be
felt in our downtown it would be felt
more in the outer portions of our city
because according to our current zoning
regulations this type of housing can be
built by Wright in just about everywhere
in the center of the city we do have
quite a lot of triple Deckers and other
homes we are still missing
proportionally you know the middle
missing housing
but yeah so for example I live in the
North End of Manchester Ward one we are
primarily single family whether it's
um I guess medium density or high
density single family zoning it's still
single family so that's where the impact
of this would be felt in my community
specifically and Manchester is going
through a land use code update process
that has been taking a little longer
than expected we don't have anything
public yet
um but I guess from my testimony you can
tell where I will fall when we do
discuss this publicly as a board later
this year thank you
representative Brown
So In Your Capacity as a professional
planner would you think that this bill
would fit more appropriately in cities
or towns of a certain size
thank you for your question and I I do
agree in part um I do think that it's
important to make sure that uh any sort
of
new development really fits the context
of the community to a certain degree I
think this bill adequately does take
that into account by making sure that it
only applies to lots that already have
Municipal Water and Sewer and there has
been discussion about you know the
adequate capacity of that but I do think
the town uh or city if it has concerns
with existing capacity of its um sewer
or water supply that could come into the
conversation there but I think this bill
is tailored in a way that does address
go ahead turn your mic on
so with with what's been said about this
uh water or sewer hookups a lot of uh
towns have sewer lines that extend it
out to developments that would go by
areas that aren't developed now so do
you think as a planner that this
ruling would cover
those uh lots that that sewer line had
been specifically designed for
that's a great question my understanding
or at least my perception of this
legislation proposed legislation would
be that
um usually infrastructure runs you know
maybe under the street and if the
property abuts that Street then I think
that it would be technically serviced by
it and I do also want to suggest that if
municipalities uh are concerned about
the cost uh you know the added cost of
maintaining or building new
infrastructure for water or sewer
related to more development there are
impact fees that are specifically
enabled by the state of New Hampshire
I'd have to double check to make sure it
applies to sewer and water but I'm
pretty sure it does I know it applies in
Manchester we use it for school impact
fees and also for fire impact fees
response yeah
one quick question and seeing no more um
did you say you're a homeowner in
Manchester I am yes uh I was very
fortunate and got in before the market
went crazy in 2018. okay
um the other quick question question uh
you mentioned the words free will
freedom
which I am totally in agreement with you
on so my question would be as a
purchaser for a home in New in North End
of Manchester did you do so under your
own free will I did so yes thank you
please
all right thank you very much thank you
good afternoon my name is Lisa Stone and
I'm a member of the planning board in
Peterborough I'm also a realtor I am
here of my own free will
um not speaking for either
um
earlier we heard a mention of character
and I would like to say that the people
who live in downtown Manchester this
week are seeing the character of
homelessness
we have a huge housing crisis
and for most of the little towns in our
state this bill probably creates one or
two units right if you own a single
family home you're not I'm I own a big
house
full of my current family I'm not going
to run out and divide my house up next
week but when I turn 70 I might and I
should have the ability to do that and
to stay home and I I just think that
when people get all wound up about the
character of their neighborhood uh
having people not be homeless in our
state which is a real reality that I
don't think that we've ever seen before
like we are seeing it now and it's
because we don't have enough housing
over and over and over you know
um currently as a realtor I can tell you
that there are 1100 houses on the market
in the entire State the average house
price being 450 but 800 of the houses
that are currently on the market are
over 450 450
000 so they're really we are so missing
thank you for your testimony
seeing no questions we'll call next uh
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee I'm Nick Taylor I'm the
executive director of the workforce
Housing Coalition of the greater
Seacoast I'll also be presenting as uh
for Alyssa margolin with housing action
New Hampshire as a member of the
governing Council of uh housing action
New Hampshire so we'll get a two for one
within three minutes here
um we are here in both cases in strong
support of House Bill 44 for many of the
reasons that were laid out already we're
hearing from businesses all across the
Seacoast that they're in desperate need
of workers they can't find them and the
employees that they do have are
continuing to leave because the commutes
are long the rents are increasing and
housing is becoming increasingly
unaffordable I think it's really clear
across New Hampshire that we need to
increase the supply of all types of
housing that includes everything from
more single-family homes to more larger
multi-family homes and everything in the
middle like this bill does
um you know the main point that I just
want to hammer home here is
as policy makers when you're increasing
Supply one of the main Tools in your
toolbox is to relax regulations and
allow for more freedom of people to
develop their property as they see fit
within reason and this is one of the
things that this bill does it would
allow for naturally occurring market
rate housing that is also generally more
affordable to our attainable for our
Workforce in a way that you know there's
no increased government funding here
there's no increased subsidies or
anything like that it's naturally
occurring market rate housing that will
inherently be more attainable to our
Workforce which is an incredible
opportunity for this Committee in this
body here and under this bill as
previous speakers have mentioned
communities maintain their ability to
regulate appearance and architecture
while still increasing housing Supply
which is very important I also have a
letter that I will hand out on behalf of
housing action New Hampshire and then
two quick events that housing New
Hampshire housing action New Hampshire
is hosting on Monday the 23rd at 4 pm
this is a virtual webinar the former
Speaker of the House in Maine Ryan
fechtow and a Republican mayor Jason
Levick our presenting Maine had just
passed a very similar Bill and then on
January 26th the bipartisan housing
caucus is hosting legislative luncheon
in the State House cafeteria we'll also
follow up an email with that
I think I got it 155 very nice I would
advise though in the future that you
keep your testimony to the specific
build and not do any advertising sure
are there any questions
uh representative uh Guthrie thank you
just a guy I wanted to talk to
has there been any consideration in
having employers provide housing like we
did back in the day
so we hear from a lot of employers who
are interested in providing housing
frequently local regulations uh whether
it's density whether it's availability
of land are actually stopping
um that from going forward and you also
have employers who you know are if
they're in the manufacturing business
they really don't want to be in the
landlord business and they don't want to
be managing the rent and the salary and
thank you Mr chairman for letting go on
our subjects thank you
representative Charlotte
once again thank you Mr chair and thanks
Mr Taylor for coming in I have two
questions for you
um how long has your organization been
in existence
we've been around since 2001 originally
formed for local businesses who are
concerned about housing and they still
for chap s and or sites do you have
uh we represent mostly communities in
Stratford and Rockingham counties we
don't have our own property but we we
have regularly host events with over 100
people I'm sorry follow up Mr chair
um that would be follow-up number three
but go ahead Mr eleven it's true
did you just call me Mrs treeleven I did
that
I'm rolling eyes I'm calling you miss
yeah oh my gosh it's a good thing we're
friends
thank you Mr Taylor for your patience
how many employees how many people work
for your organization and how many
volunteers have you got right now it is
just me for our organization and we have
a 10-member volunteer board uh as well
as a lot of volunteer and Coalition
members that support the mission perfect
you're welcome representative
seeing no more questions representative
Brown
just a quick question you said Maine
just recently passed a bill I know this
is New Hampshire but you said that it's
a significantly the same as this bill
can you tell me how it differs
um it was part of a larger package I
believe uh LD
2003 was their bill there was a few
other pieces to it but the the
fundamental piece of the four units with
water and sewer was the same
okay thank you for your testimony final
pink card I have I'm assuming there are
foreign
you turn on your microphone there please
okay my name is Jane Hague I live at on
Union Street in Manchester and I really
appreciate the opportunity to testify
I'll try to be brief
um since I don't really have a whole lot
to add I support this bill
uh like Bryce I'm a homeowner in the
North End of Manchester I live in an
interesting old old farmhouse that
actually used to be a duplex but I think
is now Zone single family so certainly
this would give us the opportunity to
convert it back into a duplex by right
which I think would be good but I
actually belong to the Manchester
housing Alliance we're a volunteer group
of people who have been trying to work
on solving some of the housing problems
in Manchester which actually have only
gotten worse over the last two years and
um
so um I just want to say that I think
that this is really important we have we
have a housing crisis in New Hampshire I
hope everyone is finally convinced of
that this isn't going to solve the
housing crisis in Manchester but I think
we need to take the opportunity to pass
as many things as we can that will
actually help and I think this is one of
the things that could do that as part of
my volunteer job here with the housing
Alliance I try to attend as many of
these events and do as much reading on
the subject so I attended an event with
the Federal Reserve Bank of Boston who
published a paper on how to increase
housing affordability by understanding
deterrence local deterrence to building
multi-family housing and they um their
main point was an important way to
ensure low rents and lower housing
prices and to increase the supply
which is difficult in these land
constrained metropolitan areas unless we
take up the opportunity to build more
dense housing I think Manchester is an
interesting because people talk about
the missing middle housing the three
plexes and the four plexes and eight
plexes and that is what Manchester is in
the center part of the city there's so
many of these old Victorian houses that
actually have
an adjacent or added on unit with maybe
another four or five units so you're
getting like eight units I don't think
we're going to see that but I also agree
with the previous speaker who said this
isn't going to immediately change the
character of every neighborhood in
Manchester that has water and sewer
people aren't going to jump in and start
doing this wholesale I don't think it's
going to change anything for a couple
years actually so
um
I hope that we can begin to adopt this
and other other ordinances like the Adu
bills and so forth
and incentivize cities to actually add
Municipal Water and Sewer that's all I
are there any questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
and uh just so everybody knows we have a
blue sheet there were 10 signed in for
it none against and with that I will
close the hearing on HB 44 and with that
foreign
do you have a question representative
yeah sorry just um uh I I
am questioning my hearing
um uh for the reading of the blue shade
numbers there I couldn't quite tell if
you said ten to nine or ten To None ten
good afternoon representative stavis I
do not have a pink card on you so I
assume you will fill that in
yes I will thank you okay representative
go ahead
um for the record my name is Laurel
stavis I represent uh Grafton 13 which
is Lebanon and specifically I represent
Ward 1 in Lebanon which is West Lebanon
uh thank you uh chairman turcotte and
members of the
honorable Municipal and County
government Community for hearing my
argument for this bill today it's a
relatively simple bill and it's in it's
in an existing law that is full of maids
but no shells
uh and so it is
the these are suggestions and guidelines
if you will for communities who are who
have planning boards and it is the duty
of the planning board to develop a
master planning process every five to
ten years
uh in um in our city of Lebanon
we recently had
a debate between the planning board and
the City Council on whether to require
new development to ins to install uh EV
charging stations as a part of their
infrastructure
um members of the planning board felt
that that was
constituted an undue burden on
developers members of the city council
disagreed
um if my bill is adopted going forward
that kind of argument won't take place
anymore but it just it adds to the
chapter on Master plans some language
that brings Master planning into the
20th maybe even the 21st century
uh and so my my suggestions which come
forward with the support of the Lebanon
planning board
uh have in them the inclusion of
chapters on the following
a transition to renewable energy section
this is in the municipal master plan so
it's just a suggestion it's not a shell
it's a May
which includes an analysis of citizens
needs for alternative sources of energy
such as EV charging stations enhanced
bike Lanes Community power generation
which this general court has already
approved
and incorporation of solar and wind
power into the area under the
jurisdiction of the planning board
and it also adds at the end any other
section addressing any other topic
relevant to the appropriate future
development of the area under the
jurisdiction of the planning board that
are not specifically enumerated in this
section so as I said it's a simple bill
it just lets planning boards and
municipalities be a little bit more
forward-looking in the way that they
develop their Municipal Master plans and
hopefully to anticipate some of the
changes that have already come down the
line and will undoubtedly be coming down
the line in the near future and I'm
happy to take any questions thank you
very much
representative treleman
thank you once again Mr chair and thank
you representative for taking my
question am I to assume you're
introducing this as a bill
I am oh I didn't hear those words come
out of your mouth so sorry I want to
representative Brown
just a quick question thank you Mr
chairman um
you mentioned that there was a debate
between the planning board and the city
council regarding charging stations so
leads me into was the debate and I'll
get to the reason for this in just a
minute was the reason for the debate
that uh
in a development plan they were going to
require charging stations by a private
developer
or private property owner or was it
something that the town was going to do
this would have been something that the
city would have required of private
developers when proposing new buildings
that they incorporate EV charging
infrastructure into their plans
well Mr Sharon follow-up so in regard to
this so I'm trying to understand the
undue burden discussion as related to
that and how
and how we transition to this bill from
that how that how that works that's an
excellent question and thank you for
asking it
um
my contention is that by incorporating
into the master planning process some
forward-thinking language that might
induce towns and cities to look forward
and incorporate some of those issues
like EV charging infrastructure into
their Municipal Master plans the debates
such as the one that we had in Lebanon
representative man chaputi
thank you Mr chair just uh
alerting that I am one of the
co-sponsors so but I'm not testifying
there so I'm sitting and asking the
question
um thank you representative for taking
the question and bringing this bill
forward how would this relate to
uh the concept of Net Zero development
where any new development
has to be
self-sustaining in terms of energy which
includes renewable passive building
charging and all that so
this
would this enable such a new development
so it's not impacting the existing grid
thank you representative for that
excellent question
um no it wouldn't it simply enables the
it enlarges the scope of what the
municipal planning board can think about
when beginning to draft a master plan
when renewing an existing master plan it
would it would not as I said before it
doesn't have any shells in it it's all
may
it just allows for a larger area of
thinking for for municipal planners to
Envision the future as opposed to Simply
uh follow-up go ahead thank you
um absolutely I I hear it it may and
it's the master plan what I'm alluding
to is there are some communities that
are requiring for the master plan any
new development has to be Net Zero
that's helping
that not have the debate in the
community between the zoning or planning
board and the municipality thank you
representative man chaputi I I'm not
familiar with those particular Municipal
Master plans my understanding of this
RSA is that the municipal Master
planning process is a planning board
tool
to help guide the planning board and the
municipality in the future use of the
jurisdiction that it oversees
uh any subsequent requirements or zoning
changes or mandates would come from the
governing body and not the planning
board that is responsible for developing
any further questions
seeing none I have a couple for you
representative
um you mentioned at the very beginning
um that the RSA 642-2
it indeed does start with a May and then
it goes into this long laundry list of
issues you you stated that you believe
and what I was considering is it a
possibility
that that make could also be interpreted
a town
May
only look at these items
or is it
may you may consider these items which
one of those do you see it as
I know it might sound like it's a fine
line but to me there's a very big
difference between a suggestive or a
restrictive word man sounds like a
philosophical conundrum actually it
interpretation and I'm just asking for
your interpretation of that I see it as
as more of a
a suggestion as as opposed to a
requirement and I will just point to the
um to lines 9 through 11.
in the proposed bill which in fact
basically says anything else
okay
I think I have to ask Sarah right now
um
do I have to accept it
the the follow-up would be if indeed it
is suggestive which
I also would tend to agree with you is
wouldn't you say that
everything after
642-2 at the top where it says may all
that laundry list of items I mean that
laundry list couldn't that laundry list
continue on and on and on or
simply have
something similar to what you have
written
it could
it's an excellent question I am not
intimately familiar with the history of
this piece of the RSA I do know that
in my tenure on the planning board in
Lebanon
that list that is enumerated in the RSA
has become very important and extremely
helpful not so much as a prescriptive or
proscriptive list but as a list of
suggested guidelines
I don't know if I'm answering your
question I don't think I am
I'm trying I'm really trying I
understand how you have responded thank
you
representative priest yeah yes thank you
very much for taking my question and
isn't it true that with the master plans
of New Hampshire
every Community is different unique and
these suggestions that are given
in the rsas are suggestions to help the
planners to think about
how to move their community
forward in the future
further questions representative Edward
thank you representative
um
would you agree that may is
discretionary
yes and
if the communities
[Music]
okay
I'm sorry I forgot my train of thought
no follow-up
representing bro
uh just another quick question so uh to
implement this it says 60 days after
passage nothing really has to be done it
just changes the RSA and was as
communities refer to the irsa as moving
forward they just look at this to help
them enable them to look at other ideas
correct that's correct thank you
for the questions representative
thank you Mr chair
um thank you representative for taking
one more question
um would you just characterize this as
an enabling
uh legislation for
future or current or future Master
planning
I'm not sure I know how to answer that
question representative man japoodi my
understanding
excuse me of this RSA
on developing Municipal Master plans
is that it specifies that it shall be
the duty of the planning board to do
this
but it is not prescriptive or
prescriptive I'm sorry getting those two
words mixed up
it is not an absolute must have for
every municipality that the RSA does not
dictate that so
I don't believe that it's enabling I
believe that it's just
a part of the duties of of town
departments
Statewide
representative Guthrie just a quick
dude thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question do you know of
communities to just take their planning
information just put it in a draw
there's no action required by that alas
I do yes as as I do thank you thanks for
your testimony seeing no more questions
uh thank you representative Davis call
uh Nature's Grace
good afternoon Mr chair and members of
the committee Nate Grace for the
municipal Association again we support
this bill it's expansion of the optional
section of the master planning sheet and
I think that your chair got exactly to
uh an an interesting point
um which is there there's a number of
things that the planning board must
consider
when creating a Master Plan and there's
a number of things they may consider
this would expand the May section
um so we're we're in favor of that but
as in terms of whether that may is
restrictive or not
um
fortunately all the land use people have
left so I will say that my
interpretation is it probably is
restrictive but if we were to enact this
lines 9 through 11 would allow them to
create whatever section is most
appropriate for their Town regardless of
what's listed above they could create
something else that's not listed above
if that's necessary so I think this is a
representative Manchester thank you Mr
chair thank you Mr Grace for uh taking
my question my question is the same one
that I asked the prime sponsor about
would this lend itself to a new
development in a master plan for
communities to think about energy
everything inclusive environmental
friendly needs of 21st century would
this enable such a community to be
planned
at this time yes it would enable
specifically because lines nine through
11 are there
anything it doesn't matter really what
the giant list is because as long as
your planning board thinks this is
relevant to your community they can add
a section into the master plan about
that
so it could be that could be something
completely opposite of that doesn't
matter
further questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
I see no more pink cards for HB 90 so we
will close the hearing on that on the
sign up sheet
have two individuals zero
John at all or doing good need a break
good all right
okay now we're going to open up the
and
Prime sponsor representative renzullo
that's fine yeah we need you to we need
me
okay
thank you
thank you Mr chair
I understand been having been in your
spot before I understand the problem
uh okay house bill 184.
would allow municipalities to post
public notice for Zoning Board of
adjustment hearings on a town website
if the town if there's if the website is
available instead of newspaper
publication now
This sounds too good to be true
it saves our constituents money it saves
our towns and cities money and it makes
life easier for Town employees
first as at the risk of repeating what
you already know many municipalities
have zoning ordinance
uh commensurate with that they have a
zoning Board of adjustment to hear an
appeals
on the strict application of an
ordinance which called variances or
appeal to the interpretation of an
ordinance by enforcement of officials to
a specific situation according to the
current
RSA section 7 6 7 6
colon seven a public hearing and a
public notice is required a Butters need
to be notified by verified mail that's
section A
of the of the law
in the
in what I passed out and I didn't give
myself a copy uh is the
there is a
copy of uh
uh six seven six
uh subsection
uh subsection seven uh
the we were not touching that subsection
that could that concerns a a Butters
notified by verified mail we're not
touching that
section B
is on newspapers
we're only adding additional good
practices the new section section c
publication on municipalities website uh
that is the big hitter
it's uh it allows uh it's cheaper
just publish it on the website rather
than publish it publish uh in a
newspaper uh it saves the cost of the
newspaper space which has been
eventually which has to be eventually
charged to the applicants
processing is easier no invoices from
the from a publisher no clerical work or
less clerical work and it's more
effective
the
no there's the notice is up longer
is this in control of the town it's on a
Town's website it's it's not a one not a
onesie it's not a not in a newspaper
it's only up for one day so it's more
effective to get the get the information
out to the public
uh so and so you're not limited by space
now to go over the bill as it's entered
hope you have
a copy
is the now you have you all you all got
a you have a copy of the bill I was
introduced hope you have uh the one the
copy with the that have that has the
numbers on it
all right if
we go through through the the bill as
introduced
and keep the keep the amendment handy
which is amendment number
okay continue if
all right just going down down the uh
the bill itself
uh
the section A
as we go down these
section one and it's section A goes the
to
goes down to to this down all the way to
section 11.
that that's where the first uh issue
well first of all the bill does uh does
not affect
okay hold up one second there
located
uh there was a packet that I passed
through that I had started around that
yeah the they were all they were all
hooked together continue okay all right
if you get down to you know you get down
on the on the uh as introduced
if
and the bill is as introduced you get
down to line 11. you'll see a crossed
out line
that says public notice of the hearing
shall be placed in a newspaper of
General circulation in the area of
General circulation
et cetera et cetera and it's crossed out
that was not supposed to be crossed out
so that so that is the first part of the
uh of amendment 0047 it is a it is pi
that is part of the existing law now
the change
which which appears on both the original
uh as introduced and then and in the uh
uh
in the amendment is the notice requires
under this section shall not include the
day
notice is posted or the day of the
public Hearing in other words it expands
the amount of
notice
It also says that notice of each public
hearing shall be published in a paper of
General circulation in the municipality
and shall be posted in let in at least
again some of that is actually in
existing law but this is you know also
is part of the amendment
the
item if you go down to item 16 and uh
line 16 in the original
bill
it's which started in lieu of
publication of a paper of General
circulation pursuant to subparagraph a
the notice may be posted in the
municipalities internet website on such
exists that
we in the we have added in the amendment
an additional sentence which also
appears in the above in section
uh in in section
uh B which says the notice required
under this sub under this section shall
not include the day notice notice is
posted and or the day of the public
hearing so that same sentence is now
will appear in section B and set and
section c
and that's those are the actually the
only changes the in the amendment
that the amendment affects now what is
this that the bill does
uh it allows I think I've just got I've
gone over it it allows us the it allows
the towns to publish
instead of publishing in a newspaper to
publish uh in uh in the uh on their own
town website and also added to this uh
are some uh the some information some
directions
uh to how it should appear
uh you know it should be approximate and
that's on the latter part portion of
of part uh part C
what
and it's it also should note
uh additional these these additions
uh are not just pulled out of thin air
they actually also and if you have a the
packet
there is a a
chapter there's there's
two
exist that there are two existing laws
the one that we're talking with is is is
colon seven if you look at
colon seven
these are requirements that for for the
zone for the planning
uh board
and if you'll notice that if there's a
little uh bracket
all of those
uh suggestions appear over up here in
in that section so these these
additional
cleanups or these improvements are
show a show that are already exists now
in another part of the uh of the of the
law uh
uh no
uh
I also noticed that this bill is FN
but it's but in the docket is not an
early bill
so uh yeah it it could go on on consent
and it because it is due on March in in
March
um in closing uh I'd like to
uh note that this bill was initiated by
uh the Hudson zoning and code
enforcement officer Bruce buttrick
uh he's speaking soon he sought me out
I guess it's the best way to improve a
system is to listen to the people who
live and work with it uh so regardless
of where the bill goes I commend him for
his efforts thank you very much
thank you uh representative renzuelo do
we have any questions representative uh
representative priests
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I have a question on
um
may find this now in the on the in the
major in the initial bill or in the uh
oh yes it's on line six and it says the
notice required under this section shall
not include the day notice is posted or
the day of the public hearing the day of
the public hearing is where I'm having
confusion
and of course with the public notice you
would have the day where the public
notice is going to be held is that
correct
right so that's why I'm confused yeah
and maybe well in other words
[Music]
um let's not have a back and forth if we
have further questions
do you have another question I have no
more questions thank you
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question my question
um pertains to section c of the bill and
that would be line 16 through 19.
it talks about
um alternatively to the the notice being
posted and that the alternate
being posted on an internet website so
my question is do you need to specify
that such a notice will be posted
electronically do you need a five-day
specification as is
noted in section B
uh
which
uh that's I think part of the
uh so
all right you mean the part that was the
existing portion uh of uh the bill and
what what line in section B okay so I I
had said that my question pertains to
section c of the bill right and I had
also noted lines 16 through 19 15 right
that's section c so I was questioning is
a specification of
um five days before the date
of the hearing does that need to be also
stated in section c as it's stated in
section b or
does that five-day reference is that
implied pointing back towards section B
it's just a clarification all right as
the it as it says see it says
uh in in the amendment
uh
uh in lieu of publication of the the
[Music]
in Louisville publication of a paper of
General circulation pursuant to
subparagraph B
notice may be posted on the
municipalities inter internet website if
such exists then it's added the notice
requires under this section shall not
include
the day notice or is posted or the day
the public hearing
it's that answer your question
follow up thank you Mr chairman I
apologize I I was in another committee
introducing a bill so I I was an error I
I was referring the original bill when I
should have been speaking about the
amendment so my question still stands I
just
foreign
I'm just it's the reference to the five
days so with regards to the amendment on
line five you specify a five-day
requirement I'm just asking if a similar
five-day requirement needs to also be
specified in section c of your Amendment
and that would somewhere within lines 9
through 13.
oh I can't understand what you're saying
the uh all right so the yeah that five
yeah that that talks about the here okay
hearing the appeal
uh I think it's the way it the way I I
read it is in lieu of publication
pursuant to the sub paragraph B so it's
uh it's a you know it refers back to
that I think the way the way I the way I
would I would read it
it refers back to the are there any five
questions
questions representative L Word
thank you representative for taking my
question
um
I'm I'm referencing
line 22
right
item two
where the notice shall be posted at the
the amendment says
Item B
uh as introduced it said a the amendment
if this is under item 22 no
this
uh this this is
the in the amendment only goes to a
those two apart as as it uh is written
it says uh it it's it only refers to the
introductory paragraph So of section of
section one so it uh or it okay so uh
you know this the that portion if you
notice it says in the notice shell
uh in the in the amendment
that
that be that is that is uh real that is
I act that is line 19 in the original
bill so with all of this what you're
eating here
additions to the uh
to
well excuse me what what you're reading
here is what's also on
uh you're reading the original bill
representative when we ask the questions
if you could speed it up this is
dragging okay relentlessly uh did you
have a follow-up representative yes so
so in your amendment in your Amendment
after line 13 it says the notice shall
colon right
what comes after that Michelle we then
it become item 20 says one appear
prominently in a website page
yeah
so it's all the questions representative
Brown
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I guess I just want
to get this clarified with the line
numbers because in the initial bill you
have lines one through
25 and then you introduced Amendment
with lines 1 through 13. yeah and then
we have lines from the original Bill 13
through 25. so you're saying that the
amendment replaces
the entire bill down to line 19 is that
correct
uh no the amendment
it says it it replaces the section
from
it replaces
part of it replaces B
a small small B and part of of C
yes I know I had that argument
could you turn off your mics please
sorry
okay
um so looking at this amendment there's
multiple problems with it so section so
you're replacing section one of the bill
um section one starts on line one and
ends on line 24 section two of the bill
is line 25. so
um that is this section that you're
replacing and so the shall colon
um is a problem still because the one
two and three were removed from this but
also it seems like there is
um a duplication of a statement that
that uh in on lines four you're no
longer Crossing out the the
um
that the public notice shall be placed
in the newspaper and then on line seven
you're restating that statement so
um I guess my question is what is the
importance of restating
um the statement that it shall be placed
in the newspaper twice in in on in the
RSA
but
representative renzulu representative
yokella I'm going to make a suggestion
yes um there is
at least with some of us some confusion
to what's actually in here
um
the amendment
in my opinion should have been prepared
in its full
full amount instead of amending pieces
of this it should have come from a full
so what I'm going to suggest so we can
hear the other individuals who would
like to testify
is that
after this hearing
you create an amendment prior to the
exact session
that spells this out as you intended
before you leave I would make have one
question and suggestion from myself
or not including a day's notice in the
day of the public hearing would it not
be simpler just to increase the five
days to seven
that second that paragraph to me is very
confusing
and leaves it open to
quite a bit of interpretation so I'm
going to leave you with that and asks um
that the rest of the committee give no
more questions please so we can get up
our next individuals thank you I I agree
we'll do it thank you and I'm not I'm
not gonna well I'm you will hear my
yelling all the way up here thank you
representative I'm going to call uh
foreign
thank you Mr chairman thank you to the
committee for taking the time to hear me
on uh HB 184. my name is Brendan McQuaid
I'm the president and publisher of the
New Hampshire union leader I am here as
the president of the New Hampshire press
Association we represent over 50
entities throughout the state from
um
small online operations to weekly daily
newspapers to broadcasters
um
a major issue with this bill
is the insinuation that posting to a
public website is notice
that's access that's not notice notice
is that someone is told what's going on
and what's clear in this bill is
it keeps the part where a Butters
receive notice by mail
but it removes the part where anyone
else who might have an interest in
something that the zoning board is doing
is going to receive notice because they
have to know to go to this presumably
town website that they may visit once a
year or never especially in towns where
there's not internet access for a lot of
people
so it's insufficient it's not notice in
our readers and readers throughout the
state of newspapers are reading the
newspaper anyway they're reading the
newspaper for other things they're
reading for local sports local news all
that sort of stuff they're going to see
the notice that's in the paper more than
they would see the notice that is on a
town website with just a you know
perhaps small link on the front page
um if you ask any
publisher or editor when a typo gets
through
we hear about it because our readers who
are very civically engaged readers read
every single thing in the newspaper and
that is notice this bill is not notice
um an important factor the newspapers
perform now is they keep a third party
record which is distinct from the record
that is produced by the
publication on a website there's no
provision in this bill to keep a record
that notice was given posted when it was
posted screenshots anything like that
that is all done currently by the
newspapers back issues are available and
most newspapers are putting that on the
web if you look at mypublicnotices.com
that's where we and a number of other
newspapers publish all of the Public
Notices that we create and they're
available to everyone no paywall
anything like that
so that function is in there currently
small newspapers obviously are seeing
economic demographic Social Challenges I
would urge this committee not to take
away a crucial role that they're
performing well and that is a crucial
function for government
public participation has to be
encouraged and public notice is a very
important part of that and this bill
clearly fails on that test
the New Hampshire press Association
feels that public participation is so
important again access is not notice and
we encourage you to find this bill in
expedient to legislate
thank you for your testimony any
questions
representative Elward
good afternoon
um would you consider a weekly Shopper
type publication uh full of local
advertisements and what not to be a
newspaper in
General
very specifically in general circulation
yeah according to the current law I
think you would have a hard time finding
a true Shopper anymore most weekly
newspapers in the state are newspapers
follow up Mr chairman uh follow-up are
you saying that the difference between a
newspaper and a shopper could hinge on
content
representative
who are we going with two down there wow
all right well we'll start with
representative gilmanson
uh thank you for taking my question
thank you Mr chair
um
foreign
there is not a paper
around where I live that publishes a
paper copy that would satisfy this
notice requirement
even you know cutting it down to the
five days that's why I understand not
counting those two days on either end
because you might see a paper within
five days as opposed to last week
do you consider the online version of a
newspaper
which is also of
choice you know not a
it's not right in front of you and your
description of what it notices would you
consider that the same as publishing in
a written newspaper of General
publication uh I would consider it
similar because those readers are going
uh to be reading that content for a
reason other than strictly going to look
for that notice but may I ask where you
live Exeter yeah
we publish daily in Exeter I can only
speak for the union leader but we
publish uh and we have subscribers in
Exeter
so we do meet the qualification thank
you
representative yokella
thank you uh I'm over here on this side
there you go sorry uh-huh no worries
um
um it's kind of a two-part question you
were talking about the distinction
between notice and um
and access
um in my local town we
um you can subscribe to the like the
town's website and they will actually
email you the notice
um of all of the Public Notices that
they're doing they're not just posting
it on the website I'm wondering if you
would consider that notice and
um based on your definition that you
stated before and is such a subscription
model to the notice also
um available on that uh the one that
you've got you have created that website
where it gets pushed out to people and
not that they have to go and look at it
um that one no uh there are options out
there for that that uh I don't know if
any of the papers in the state do now
but I would not necessarily consider
that the same level notice because again
someone actively went and sought that
out and this bill doesn't currently
require
that level of commitment for the town to
have to send those out via a dedicated
mailing list that's a wonderful service
that's being offered but that's not what
this bill currently requires and I would
point to a similar bill that passed in
Florida
um recently that bill required that if
someone signed up that they could be
mailed in the U.S mail copies of all the
notices that were done which would allow
for people that don't have internet
access or don't have computer access to
representative Manchester thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um
if a community does not have a daily
newspaper the five-day notice
would it be included in the previous
week or
we get the news
of on
Saturday mailed to us
but the news was published two weeks ago
in Union Leader or some other newspaper
so that's the news we get in a so-called
the newspaper so how do you uh
account to that that kind of community
yeah so the I'm trying to parse what
you're talking about and I'm guessing
you might get uh what's in the news
business is considered a TMC product uh
which is a free product that gets mailed
to homes that's a weekly product and we
do not run legal notices in that our
legal notices are run in the daily paper
representative
yes um can you tell me the number of
papers that are published in the state
that are daily whether they cover the
entire
um
community of the State of New Hampshire
all counties
I I don't have that off the top of my
head I can sort of name them off the top
of my head we currently have the Keen
Sentinel the Portsmouth Herald The
Fosters Daily Democrat Union Leader
um we're at the Concord Monitor and
we're all publishing uh daily papers
some of them not seven days a week some
five or six days a week but we continue
to publish that and the union leader
again I can only speak for the union
leader
we are Statewide
thank you you may follow up if you have
a question that pertains to the bill
that last question really didn't pertain
to the bill
uh Mr chairman I was basically trying to
see whether or not the people that of a
certain demographic do not
um whether they have the ability in the
state to get a daily paper in their
account okay if you have your follow-up
go ahead well that was the question
basically if everyone in the state and
all the counties have the ability to
view a daily paper that would have these
notices in them they do and and I
guarantee even if they don't get the
paper their grandmother will tell them
thank you
okay it's true though what questions
think oh
thank you thank you for your testimony
thank you Mr chair and H Grace for the
municipal Association
um we support the bill
um obviously it needs some work
um and we're happy to assist the extent
we can on that
um I don't really have much to say other
than that except I just want to point
out to the committee because I know you
don't receive these bills that uh
Municipal notices are subject to the
right to no law and there are certain
um regulations relating to how long
those have to be kept
those would be found in RSA 33 hyphen a
colon 3 hyphen a so
um if anyone has any questions about
those happy to answer that
I have one question for you yes
um
the notification process uh the previous
individual given the testimony mentioned
they also put these on notification
electronic memes also in their pages is
would you consider that the Fulfillment
of the notification requirement
in lieu of the physical paper
so that's a good question and I don't
have a good answer for it because there
is a definition for the term newspaper
under chapter 21 I believe it is 20 or
um and I believe the implication is it
has to be printed a newspaper is a
printed material not it doesn't I don't
believe it encompasses online
representative majbooty
thank you Mr chair
on line 16 the bill says 16 to 19 in
lieu of publication
in a paper
and you can publish it online on website
do you believe that every Community
every municipality has that capability
to publish things on their website and
that broadband and um
is available
no and that's why it's a local option so
what we would encourage municious about
is to do is to do whatever is going to
going to get the word out best to their
community
so in some communities like Fremont
where you can subscribe to the local
notices from your town they're going to
have a pretty big subscriber base I
assume because it's a small community
and they're going to be very interested
in what's happening in their community
so that's going to touch upon a lot of
people there in other communities
um
I can't think of one off the top of my
head but a small rural community like
maybe Danville isn't necessarily going
to have
that kind of website built out
um so for them they might have more
printed news that's available and it
would be a better option to to use the
thank you for Testimony seeing no more
questions thank you Mitch thank you
appreciate it uh last pin code we have
for this is Bruce I cannot
thank you Mr chair
members of the committee's Bruce
as representative renzullo it indicated
I had approached him to uh help modify
the particular
to give you some history legislature
approved a similar amendment in 2020
that was RSA 675 colon six six
and that was the same requirement that
planning boards
had to do
they did this very same we basically
replicated what that amendment was in
2020.
thus I'm obviously in favor of this
proposal as well as the amendment for
clarification that Amendment
actually would be from line 11
through 19 on the original
draft
so if you take that out
and insert the amendment it clarifies
what the amendment was going to do
it had been a typo and had struck a
requirement that we didn't want to so we
eliminated and kept that the newspaper
notice would be required if you don't
have the internet capabilities
if you choose to do the internet
capability
then you don't have to do the required
so basically this proposed amendment to
RSA 676 colon 7 I Roman numeral I would
relieve the Zoning Board of adjustment
from the requirement posting the hearing
notice in a newspaper of General
circulation in the area if certain other
stipulations are satisfied
and that's the conditions within the
Internet Posting
we all know the increasing scarcity of
local newspapers in print in the last
several years
this has forced the zba to find the next
level up of local newspapers
basically it defaulted to a Statewide
publication
this became more expensive to the
applicant as well as to the town staff
in preparing the required notice within
the time frames of deadlines for
publication that tricky once that
five-day notice not counting the hearing
of the day of the publication
because of the newspapers schedules and
publications
those expenses are to be paid in advance
by the applicant of which tends to be
costlier with Statewide Publications
this proposed amendment of eliminating
required newspaper notice would actually
be a cost savings to the applicant the
costs associated with the newspaper
notice requirement enjoys the economies
of scale
situation when we had five cases the
cost per case is less because of the the
typeset the borders for Town gets uh
prorated across five versus one case
in our town we had to
re-calculate our application fees
we use an average three hearings
we've derived the cost of 72 dollars
directly to the applicant as part of the
application advertising fee we had to
charge the applicant
this proposed amendment of eliminating
the required newspaper notice would also
be a cost and Time Savings to the
municipality
this eliminates the process of writing
the draft notice for the newspaper
receiving the proof and then authorizing
for publication
as well as being mindful of the required
deadlines to meet the not less than five
days prior to the date of the hearing
this would also eliminate writing
purchase orders and processing invoices
between the municipality and the
newspaper
we currently use the town's website to
publish upcoming CBA meetings and
hearings on the town's website calendar
as well as the cba's page
we also provide a direct link to the
application the plans the staff report
it's known as the e-packet
it's sent via the United States Postal
Service to those EBA members for their
hard copy
and it's also available to public read
on the internet
my conclusion for you this proposed
amendment does save the applicants and
the municipality time and expenses
I'll take any questions thank you for a
seeing none thank you very much
thank you I have no more red cards
I have one uh on the blue sheet I have
one con
and we are down to our last hearing uh
foreign
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee uh for the record
um my name is representative Julie
Gilman uh from Rockingham District 11
representing Exeter
this bill is uh provides is relative to
the proration of property tax exemptions
and provides that if an individual is
eligible for property tax exemption for
the blind disabled deaf or severely
hearing impaired or elderly and owns a
fractional interest in property the
exemption amount shall be prorated based
on the amount of their fractional
interest in the property
and first I'll address the amendment
all the amendment does is add on to the
original bill as introduced to
be sure and and put into statute that
the other rsas that are mentioned in the
document do not have to be revoted by or
thank you for introducing the Bill thank
you for your testimony
since you're not the sponsor or
involved with it I want to assume that
thank you for your testimony
go ahead make sure your mic's on though
is that better that's better
um my name is Jim micho I'm the chief
assessor for the town of Hudson and I
want to thank you for the opportunity to
testify in favor of House Bill 197 today
I first want to also thank the sponsor
and co-sponsors representative Maggiore
and representative ulery
so uh as an assessor we administer
exemptions credits and property taxes
within our administration of the of the
property tax and currently if someone
owns a fractional interest in real
estate and they have an elderly
exemption they're only receiving 50 of
that exemption
but that RSA 72 colon 41 does not
reference that the citations for
disabled deaf or blind so if I'm
disabled in a community and I only have
a fractional interest I'm actually
receiving the entire amount of the
exemption
so this proposal is to basically restore
Equity or make it so that regardless of
the exemption that you have you will
only get the amount of the exemption
that is in proportion to your fractional
interest the prototypical fractional
interest would be in a deed and it says
I own 50 percent
and another person owns 50 I live there
I'm elderly I get the 50
um if you take that back pattern apply
it to disabled that person now is
getting 100 of that exemption and that's
usually not done in any in any laws
um also for veterans credits that's
already in in the law that if I have a
50 interest I'm only getting fifty
percent of my veterans credit so this
just seeks to uh treat people in a
similar manner based upon their interest
um the other fractional interest that
you would run into is tenants in common
so tenants in common if there's two
people on the property and they own it
as tenants in common that's
automatically 50 a piece
um so those are the two types of
fractional interests so we talk about
it's in the deed first of all
it either says 50 percent
30 percent whatever the percentage is
there's not many of these so in Hudson
um I think I have one elderly exemption
with a fractional I have maybe nine
veterans credits with a fractional we
used to have it disabled with a
fractional they pointed out they get 100
of the exemption they were correct so
we're just trying to
um I guess fix an oversight maybe within
the statute
that is the expense extent of my
testimony
thank you for your testimony are there
questions
representative 211.
once again thank you Mr chair and it's
nice to see you again thanks for coming
in I have a question about
I understand that uh
a widow of a veteran receives
the veterans exemption
in town until she or he excuse me at
which time remarries is that correct
that's correct they receive a veterans
credit gotcha veterans credit
um
should that person not marry their
partner whomever that might be yet they
live together and they have a deed in
both their names would this fractional
um interest apply to the amount of
credit they would receive thank you for
the question uh so if they hold their
property as joint tenants with rights of
survivorship yes that is non-severable
for purposes of the exemptions and
credit statutes so they would you're
welcome
seeing no more hands raised thank you
last pink card of the day Catherine heck
good afternoon committee members the
last pink card of the day very exciting
I'm going to be extremely brief and let
you know that the New Hampshire
Municipal Association supports this
legislation it's just trying to seek to
correct the issue of exemptions and
credits being fair and Equitable as you
heard in testimony yesterday with 643
000 households and 67 000 exemptions and
credits granted in the state in 2021 or
about 10 percent we just want that to be
fair and Equitable throughout the law so
that will conclude my testimony and I'll
try to keep it under 30 seconds thank
you
very good
are there any questions for
Catherine heck
seeing none I thank you for your
testimony and with that we have a blue
sign-in sheet with no names on it I'll